und heute geht es gleich am Anfang um
den größten einzeletat Arbeit und
Soziales
166,2 Milliarden Euro hat Hubertus Heil
zur Verfügung und darin ist auch das
Bürgergeld und wir haben es ja schon
eben in den Berichten gesehen gestern
Abend hat sich der Vermittlungsausschuss
geeinigt und damit wird das Bürgergeld
Morgen ohne Beratung hier im Bundestag
und im Bundesrat verabschiedet werden
können und zum ersten Januar in Kraft
treten können daran ist kein Zweifel
mehr es sollte das Meisterstück von
Hubertus Heil werden das Bürgergeld was
ist davon übrig nach dem Kompromiss
darüber möchte ich jetzt reden mit
meinen beiden Gästen ich begrüße Irene
Michalitsch sie sind Mitglied in diesem
Vermittlungsausschuss und erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführerin der
Bündnis grün und Stefan Müller ebenfalls
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Union aber auch Mitglied im Ausschuss in
diesem Vermittlungsausschuss über den
wir ganz kurz reden wollen Frau
mechanisch es kam glaube ich um 20:29
über die Agenturen Einigung das war doch
gestern Abend nur noch pro oder wir
haben schon natürlich ausführlich noch
mal über den Vorschlag des
Arbeitsministeriums beraten und haben
dann am Ende des Vermittlungsausschusses
halt eben diese Einigung gefunden die
wirklich also die Geschichte oder das
Ende der Geschichte von Hartz IV so will
ich es mal ausdrücken wirklich markiert
und ich bin wirklich froh dass wir am
Ende dieser langen Beratung auch
wirklich zu einem guten Kompromiss
gekommen sind die Union so sehen ist
viele Kommentatoren hat viel rein
verhandeln können Herr Müller sind sie
denn rundum zufrieden das ist ein gutes
Ergebnis dass wir da gestern gefunden
haben es bleibt bei dem bewährten
Prinzip fördern und fördern das heißt es
wird auch weiterhin Mitwirkungen
erwartet das sind Sanktionsmöglichkeiten
auch weiterhin möglich und es kommt eben
nicht zu einer Rückabwicklung der
erfolgreichen Arbeitsmarktreformen die
wir vor vielen Jahren gemeinsam als
Union mit rot grün beschlossen haben und
es wird auch keinen Einstieg ins
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen geben so
wie es eben auch ursprünglich geplant
war Frau engelmeyer Vorsitzende des
Sozialverbandes sagt die Streich der
vertrauenszeit damit sei das Herzstück
dieser Reform genommen teilen Sie diese
Meinung ich würde eher sagen dass das
Herzstück der Reformen weitgehend
erhalten geblieben ist der das Herzstück
der Reform ist ja dass Menschen eben
nicht mehr in jede x-billige bearbeit
sozusagen gezwungen werden ja also dass
dieser sogenannte vermittlungsvorrang
fällt im hartz4-system ist es ja so dass
Menschen also wirklich jede Arbeit
annehmen mussten einfach nur damit sie
irgendeine Beschäftigung haben das fällt
weg sondern es steht jetzt im Vorrang
dass wir die Menschen weiter
qualifizieren dass wir sie weiterbilden
und eben auch nachhaltig eben in
Beschäftigung bringen damit dieser
drehtüreffekt und diese ewige Spirale
zwischen Beschäftigung und Jobcenter
endlich aufgelöst wird und das ist
wirklich das Kernelement auch ja das
bürgergeldansatzes Menschen eben weiter
zu qualifizieren und eben nicht in jede
x-beliebige Beschäftigung zu zwingen und
das ist ein wichtiges Kernelement was
wir halten konnten Friedrich März hat
vor der Einigung noch am Wochenende
gesagt also es kommt darauf an für uns
dass Menschen schnell wieder in den
Arbeitsmarkt integriert werden gerade
angesprochen dieses weiter fördern und
weiter bilden steht jetzt mehr im
Mittelpunkt als die schnelle
Arbeitsvermittlung das widerspricht sich
ja eigentlich aber wenn man die Reform
wenn man sich Hartz IV anguckt in den
letzten Jahren war es ja oft so die
Leute gegen ihn holten sich ihren
Stempel ab und waren dann nach einer
Woche wieder beim Arbeitsamt so ungefähr
zumindest nur umso wichtiger ist es ja
dass auch es weiterhin
Mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten gibt und das
für den Fall dass eben Mitwirkung
verweigert wird auch eine Möglichkeit
besteht zu sanktionieren da kommt im
übrigen gar nicht auf die Zahl derer an
die bisher schon von Sanktionen
betroffen waren sondern die
zuständigen Behörden die Ämter brauchen
dieses Instrument das ist im übrigen
auch die Rückmeldung die wir ja gerade
von dem Praktikern von vor Ort bekommen
dass sie ohne dieses Instrument
jedenfalls einiges an
Handlungsmöglichkeiten gerade nicht
haben niemand wird widersprechen und es
war auch nie Teil unserer Kritik dass es
auch um Weiterbildung gehen muss
natürlich muss es Weiterbildung geben
und es ist ohne Zweifel richtiger und
wichtiger als es vielleicht zu dem
Zeitpunkt war wie wir er Hartz IV
Reformen gemeinsam beschlossen haben und
wie wir über Massenarbeitslosigkeit
geredet haben aber ich wiederhole noch
mal das war nie Ansatz unserer Kritik
ich finde richtig dass wir das tun das
ist auch um Weiterbildung geht es muss
aber auch darum gehen dass dann wenn es
um eine Arbeitsvermittlung geht dann
eben auch die Möglichkeit sozusagen
geben muss dann da auch entsprechende
Vorschläge zu machen Angebote zu machen
und die dann auch angenommen werden
müssen im übrigen passt allerdings
leider nicht ganz zusammen wenn jetzt
die Ampel sagt es geht hier um
Weiterbildung der stellen wir in den
Fokus gleichzeitig aber in dem Haus
seitdem wir gleich beraten werden die
Mittel für den Eingliederungstitel aus
dem diese Weite Bildung bezahlt wird um
400 Millionen gekürzt wird okay die
Frage hätte ich auch gestellt das ist
unlogisch 400 000 sind weniger
eingestellt worden gerade in einer
Reform die ja Wert legt auf die
Weiterbildung und wenn man sieht das
ungefähr zwei Drittel der Menschen die
sich bei den Jobcentern melden
eigentlich keine Ausbildung haben dann
scheint es ja auch notwendig diese
Menschen vorzubilden aber dann brauchen
wir auch das Geld dafür oder nicht
natürlich ist es absolut notwendig dass
man diese Menschen fortbildet dass man
sie weiter qualifiziert um sie auch in
nachhaltige Beschäftigung zu bringen das
wichtige beim Bürgergeld ist aber auf
jeden Fall dass wir diesen
Paradigmenwechsel auch in den Jobcentern
haben dass wir wirklich eine Beratung
darauf Augenhöhe ermöglichen dass
wirklich also die Betroffenen und auch
die Jobcenter eine
Kooperationsvereinbarung miteinander
abschließen die wirklich individuelle
Schau individuell schaut welche
Maßnahmen sind eigentlich im konkreten
Einzelfall erforderlich um Menschen
wirklich nachhaltig wieder in
beschäftigen zu bringen und das ist
sozusagen auch der Einstieg in den
Systemwechsel wenn wir wegkommen wollen
von Hartz IV hin zu einem nachhaltigen
Bürgergeld und das ist wichtig und dabei
ist es auch wichtig dass eben nicht
sozusagen bei der ersten Ansprache durch
das Jobcenter beim ersten Brief den die
Menschen bekommen gleich zwei Seiten
sanktionsanrohrungen dabei sind auch das
fällt weg ja also auch da wird sozusagen
den Menschen viel mehr auf Augenhöhe mit
Meer Respekt eben auch begegnet damit
eben auch tatsächlich die Menschen auch
in die Lage versetzt werden sich um eine
Arbeitsaufnahme zu kümmern und sich
nicht erstmal Gedanken darum machen zu
müssen okay was droht mir eigentlich
wenn ich jetzt dieses oder jenes
vielleicht nicht hundertprozentig
einhalte also die Menschen werden
wirklich auch in die Lage versetzt sich
darauf zu konzentrieren wieder
nachhaltig in Beschäftigung zu kommen
und eben auch Weiterbildungsangebote
Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen anzunehmen und
auch wirklich nachhaltig davon zu
profitieren da muss ich noch mal
nachfragen Herr Müller dass der
kooperationsplan den jeder einzelne
Arbeitslose kriegt mit seinem Job
Berater der sieht aber doch wenn ich
Hermann Gröhe gestern verstanden habe
vor dass eine Rechtsbelehrung in schon
beim ersten Tag stattfinden wird oder so
interpretiere ich das in der Tat auch
übrigens diese Kooperationsvereinbarung
die gibt es ja heute schon also wir
haben ja heute schon die Situation dass
wenn ein Mensch von einem Arbeitnehmer
ein Arbeitsloser Mensch dann hat sie
tatsächlich in den all die zwei Bezug
fällt nachdem immer dann
Arbeitslosengeld 1 bekommen hat heute ja
auch schon mit seinem zuständigen
Sachbearbeiter Sachbearbeiterin als
solche Kooperationsvereinbarung
abschließt und jedenfalls nach den
Gesprächen die ich geführt habe auch
gerade in den letzten Wochen ist es
heute auch schon so dass er eine solche
Vereinbarung gemacht wird dass auch
darüber geredet wird wo kann es
Weiterbildung geben das aber ja in der
Tat auch darauf hingewiesen wird dass
man von der betroffenen Person auch
erwartet dass sie da entsprechend
mitwirkt und diese
Mitwirkungsmöglichkeiten auch verbunden
damit zu sagen was passiert wenn du
nicht mitwirkst die wären dann eben weg
gewesen und insofern sage ich ist es ein
gutes Ergebnis es bleibt bei dieser
Kooperationsvereinbarung es bleibt beim
Angebot auch von Weiterbildung dort wo
es Sinn macht bzw auch mit Angeboten die
Sinn macht das ist ja auch Sinn machen
die auch entscheidet auch entscheidend
und trotzdem bleibt es auch dabei dass
man sagen kann wir erwarten von dir aber
auch dass du mitwirkst Hartz IV 2005
beschlossen dann endgültig fand ja zu
einer Zeit statt da gab es über 5
Millionen Arbeitslose in Deutschland
heute ist das ganz anders es müsste doch
eigentlich für jemand der arbeitslos
wird und den Jobcenter geht relativ
einfach sein einen der vielen freien
Jobs zu finden der ungefähr auf seinen
Möglichkeiten entspricht
ja das ist eben leider nicht so einfach
also ich selber komme aus einer Stadt
ich glaube mit der höchsten SGB iiquote
im ganzen Land ja also mit dem mit den
Menschen also wo die meisten Menschen
also wirklich also auch ein Hartz IV
Bezug haben die eben erwerbslos sind und
da sieht man einfach auch was das
lebenspraktisch einfach bedeutet unter
welchen Umständen halt eben auch
Menschen wenn sie ihre Arbeit verlieren
dann wirklich auch vielleicht auch
Vermittlungshemmnisse haben eben weil
vielleicht die nötige Qualifikation
nicht vorliegt einfach weil vielleicht
Weiterbildung noch nicht in Anspruch
genommen werden konnte und deswegen sind
ja eben diese Kernelemente auch so
wahnsinnig wichtig also wenn es so
einfach wäre zu sagen okay wir haben ja
auf der Seite viele Erwerbslose und auf
der anderen Seite viele offene Stellen
und dann vermitteln wie mal eben so eins
zu eins oder dann dann bräuchten wir
diese Arbeitsmarktreform ja auch nicht
wo eben auch Weiterbildung verliebte
Nationen Vordergrund steht also das
heißt dass das erhalten geblieben ist
das ist wirklich wahnsinnig wichtig und
vor allen Dingen dass die Menschen auch
wirklich in die Lage versetzt werden
sich um die Jobsuche zu kümmern und zum
Beispiel bei dem erhalte schon Vermögens
eben nicht darüber nach müssen ob sie
morgen umziehen müssen oder ob sie
erstmal ihre Altersvorsorge aufgeben
müssen auch das hat ja etwas mit Respekt
und noch Vertrauen in die Menschen zu
tun und dass wir diese Kernelemente
erhalten konnten ist wirklich sehr sehr
wichtig und damit muss ich noch mal
sagen Hartz IV ist Geschichte
Schonvermögen ist ein wichtiges
Stichwort da hat er die FDP vor allen
Dingen darauf hingearbeitet dass man zum
Beispiel Altersversorgung behalten darf
das gilt für kleine Unternehmer die sich
was zur Seite gelegt haben das ist mir
noch nicht so ganz klar geworden denn
die Staffelung auf 40.000 für den ersten
15 für die weiteren Personen im Haushalt
die sind allen Teilen bekannt aber
darüber hinaus so habe ich zumindest ein
Vogel von der FDP verstanden gibt es
gerade für diese Personengruppe noch die
Chance geben diese Alterssicherung
erstmal zu retten für ein Jahr und was
der Vogel gemeint müssen Sie natürlich
selber fragen ich kann sagen und so war
das ein wichtiger Punkt ganz einfach
weil in der jetzigen Zeit nicht
vermittelbar ist dass diejenigen die
keine Beschäftigung haben tatsächlich
ist sehr viel von ihrem Vermögen nicht
aufbrauchen müssen werden wir
gleichzeitig erleben dass viele
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer in
diesem Land angesichts der steigenden
Preise dann eben ja gerade auch ihr
Vermögen aufbrauchen und übrigens erst
recht auch Handwerker wir alle sind doch
gerade viel unterwegs reden zum Beispiel
mit dem Bäckern die er da vor einigen
Wochen auch besonders im Fokus standen
die mir mitteilen sie brauchen ja gerade
jetzt wo sie eben auch von diesem
Preissteigerung betroffen sind vieles
von ihrem Vermögen auf das für die
Altersversorgung gedacht war und
insofern hätte das was vorgeschlagen war
definitiv einen falschen Anreiz gesetzt
auch ein falsches Signal was die Frage
dessen angeht was kann man jemand
leisten muss sich Leistung auch wieder
lohnen und muss sich auch lohnen dass
man für sein Alter etwas zurücklegen die
Menschen besser qualifizieren bedeutet
eigentlich auch länger im Jobcenter sich
aufzuhalten auch häufiger zu kommen
schätzungsweise jedenfalls sind die
Mitarbeiter im Jobcenter eigentlich
jetzt schon völlig ausgelastet wie viele
neue stellen wollen Sie denn einrichten
und wie soll das Problem gelöst werden
es ist natürlich wichtig dass die
Jobcenter gut ausgestattet sind deswegen
was uns ja auch so wichtig dass das
Bürgergeld schnell in Kraft treten kann
also dass wir jetzt wirklich diese
Reform zum 1 Januar ja also auch
tatsächlich einführen können eben um
auch den Jobcentern die Möglichkeit zu
geben sich da entsprechend aufzustellen
und halt eben auch das Personal dafür
vorzuhalten diese
Qualifizierungsmaßnahmen auch diese
vielen Gespräche zu führen das ist
selbstverständlich wichtig und deswegen
bin ich ja auch so froh dass jetzt
dieser Kompromiss gelungen ist der
natürlich ein paar Dinge enthält mit
denen wir die wir uns anders gewünscht
hätten ja so ehrlich muss man natürlich
sein aber ich glaube so ist es halt eben
am Ende der Union auch gegangen jetzt
haben sich beide Seiten aufeinander zu
bewegt und wir haben ein gutes
einigungspaket geschnürt und wenn jetzt
der Deutsche Bundestag zustimmt und der
Bundesrat auch und das Bürgergeld in
Kraft treten kann wenn ich mir sicher
sind wir insgesamt auf einem guten Weg
Hubertus Heil war gestern als letzte
Redner der für die Presse gegen quasi
anzumerken wie früher er ist dass er der
Minister sein wird dir dieses ungeliebte
Hartz IV beiseiteschieben wird er hat
aber auch etwas gesagt was für von
Andrea Nahles und auch von den
Mitarbeitern der Jobcenter gehört haben
zum ersten Januar ist diese Reform eben
nicht umzusetzen dass das Geld also die
Steigerung ja für die einzelnen Menschen
aber die weiteren Reformschritte völlig
unmöglich in der jetzigen Verfasstheit
der Jobcenter auch übrigens mit den
Personal was dazu Verfügung steht was
hat er denn dazu im Ausschuss gesagt
tatsächlich war das der vom kein Thema
was jedenfalls die Frage angeht wie es
dann konkret vor Ort umgesetzt werden
soll das ist ja auch etwas was im
übrigen wieder wir im Bundestag noch
auch des Ministerium mit am Ende machen
kann sondern es kommt darauf an wie
läuft es jetzt in der Bundesagentur wie
läuft's in den Jobcentern vor Ort oder
eben bei den Kommunen es gibt ja auch
eine ganze Reihe von Kommunen die diesen
eigenen Zuständigkeit machen die
früheren options Kommunen also insofern
wird man mal abwarten ich fand es
jedenfalls auch sehr bemerkenswert weil
es so in der Diskussion jedenfalls nach
meinem Gefühl und nicht stattgefunden
hat oder nicht diskutiert worden ist
aber entscheidend ist ja am Ende dass es
dann auch tatsächlich funktioniert und
ob es dann tatsächlich zum ersten Januar
ist oder zum ersten März ist
ehrlicherweise für mich jetzt nicht ganz
so relevant wir wollen dass es
funktioniert das ist richtig und wir
wollen dort anknüpfen wo wir vor vielen
Jahren auch gemeinsam diese
Arbeitsmarktreformen auch beraten und
geschlossen haben es waren die
erfolgreichsten Arbeitsmarktreformen und
die wollten wir nicht zurück für die
Arbeitslosen die Arbeit suchen dann ist
das sehr relevant ab wann das
funktioniert auch das genau dann aber
auch für die Jobcenter Mitarbeiter ich
muss noch mal darauf zurückkommen es
soll ein Wohngeld eingeführt werden dass
wir die auch belasten und zum Beispiel
die Ukrainer die ja nun massenweise und
schätzungsweise in den kommenden Wochen
und Monaten ich will sicher beirreden
noch mehr nach Deutschland kommen müssen
und wollen die landen alle gleich beim
Jobcenter also noch mal die Frage diese
Reform ist sehr ehrgeizig wird die
ausgeführt auf dem Rücken der
Mitarbeiter der Jobcenter natürlich
nicht also selbstverständlich ist die
Reform ehrgeizig und sie haben die
Probleme angesprochen mit denen nicht
nur die Jobcenter sondern auch die
Kommunen konfrontiert sind und deswegen
ist es natürlich unsere Aufgabe ihre
Form so auszugestalten dass sie am Ende
auch ihre Wirkung entfalten kann und
eben nicht auf dem Rücken ja der
Beschäftigten in den Einrichtungen
ausgetragen wird und deswegen wird es
dort natürlich auch zu Veränderungen
kommen müssen auch wieder Müller vorher
noch zutreffend gesagt hat auch die
Arbeitsagentur wird sich natürlich da
Gedanken machen müssen wie sie diese
Reform am besten umsetzt mir ist wichtig
dass das Gesetz wirklich jetzt am ersten
Januar in Kraft treten kann eben damit
auch die Reformschritte die er
alternative dann eintreten sollen auch
sorgfältig vorbereitet werden können
auch darum geht es ja wenn wir jetzt mit
der Gesetzgebung Verzögerungen gehabt
hätten hätte sich alles nach hinten
verschoben davon hätten die Menschen
nichts gehabt davon hätten aber auch die
Jobcenter nicht gehabt oder noch die
Kommunen nicht oder die anderen
Einrichtungen und deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir auch hier im Zeitplan
geblieben sind Herr Müller wir reden
über das Bürgergeld weil es in den Etat
des bundesarbeitsministers fällt und
dessen Gesetzentwurf ist verabschiedet
wird das morgen hier ohne Diskussion das
ist sicherlich nur noch Formsache wie
ist es im Bundesrat sehen sie da noch
Probleme oder wird das so durchgehen ich
sehe keine Probleme es waren ja gestern
alle Bundesländer auch vertreten des
Abstimmungsergebnis war eindeutig wir
hatten eine Reihe von auch Ablehnungen
aber was jedenfalls die Bundesländer
angeht war da ebenfalls die Auffassung
fast einhellig das auch das dazugestimmt
wird und ich gehe davon aus dass sich
das Abstimmungsverhalten gestern Abend
im Vermittlungsausschuss nicht von dem
unterscheidet was morgen im Bundesrat
passiert wenn die Ablehnung kam von der
AFD die wollen mit einer Einstellung
sicherlich interessanter heißt die Linke
aber Frau mechanic das Ding ist jetzt
durch oder ja da gab es einen Enthaltung
und darüber sind wir auch froh dass es
also mit einer breiten Mehrheit jetzt
getragen wurde oder dass dieser
Kompromiss eben auch mit einer breiten
Mehrheit
Vermittlungsausschuss getragen wurde
deswegen bin ich sehr zuversichtlich für
die Abstimmung am Freitag im Bundestag
und auch im Bundesrat und ja damit kann
es endlich losgehen am besten immer
apropos losgehen drinnen geht's jetzt
los vielen dank vielen Dank Herr Müller
und ich gebe rein
wir setzen die Haushaltsberatungen fort
ich rufe auf
den Einzelplan 11
Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales mit den Beschlussempfehlungen
des Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
3.511 und
3.526
Berichterstattung haben die Abgeordneten
Katrin Michel dr Silke launert Markus
Kurth Claudia Raffelhüschen Ulrike
Schilke Ziesing und dr Gesine Lötzsch
hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag der
Fraktion der CDU CSU vor für die
Aussprache wurde eine Dauer von 90
Minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die Aussprache und zuerst
hat das Wort für die cdu/csu-fraktion DR
Silke launert
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren in wenigen Tagen
beginnt die Adventszeit mit Zeit der
Besinnung und der Vorfreude ja gespannt
öffnen die Kinder jeden Tag ein Türchen
des Adventskalenders und des Gipfel dann
im Weihnachtsfest heutzutage ein Fest
der Geschenke auch in diesem Jahr ist
aber vieles anders denn für die meisten
ja wird es wohl deutlich weniger und dem
unter dem Weihnachtsbaum geben die
explodieren Gas und Lebensmittelpreise
betreffen jeden in allen Bereichen jeden
einzelnen Haushalt jede Familie und das
jetzt nicht nur bei den Geschenken
sondern bei den ganz
existenziellen Sachen Strom Gas bezahlen
denn mit dir Bezahlen von Lebensmitteln
es geht schlicht und darum dabei
bei vielen Menschen darum ob sie frieren
und ob sie sich noch gesundes Essen
leisten können
schaut man sich allerdings den
Haushaltsplan unserer Bundesregierung an
da könnte man durchaus meinen alles ist
wie immer nein sogar besser der Gaben
Tisch ist reich gefüllt und die Wünsche
der Koalitionäre finden da auch ihren
Platz und dabei so könnte man meinen sei
die frohe Botschaft der Ampel dem
weihnachtlichen Koalition Frieden steht
nichts entgegen wie gesagt Wünsche
erfüllt bis hin zu den Milliarden für
das Schiff Rettungsschiff von dem
Partner von Frau Trinkgeld dabei ist die
ehrliche Lage doch eine andere wir haben
es geschafft Hunde unsere diesen
Finanzminister in dem Jahr verteilt
natürlich auch mehrere Haushalte clever
gemacht fast 550
Milliarden neue Schulden anzuvisieren in
diesem Etat für nächstes Jahr 45,6
Milliarden neu Verschuldung bis ans
Grenze Ausreißen der Schulden Obergrenze
in einer Situation
wo jeder andere Bürger jeder Haushalt
jedes Unternehmen gucken muss sparen
muss umschichten muss Prioritäten setzen
muss es ist nicht so dass wir dieses
Hilfspaket auch mit 200 Milliarden in
der Sache zum Überbrücken nicht teilen
wir haben schon frühzeitig auch Anträge
im Plenum ich glaube im März zu dem Juni
war es schon gestellt für diese Gas und
strompreisbremse da haben sie noch
Monate lang nichts getan aber es ist
doch klar es ist eine Überbrückung wir
können nicht auf Dauer nur ganz große
Milliardenbeträge in den Raum stellen
und glauben dass das Problem löst es ist
also wichtig
Schwerpunkte zu setzen statt Gießkanne
verantwortlich langfristig ist planen
statt Koalitionsfrieden sparen statt
Angst vor Auseinandersetzung und
entscheidend ist und bleibt man kann es
nicht oft genug sagen nicht nur
symptombehandlungssachen
Ursachenbekämpfung Energieangebot
erhöhen erhöhen erhöhen Ideologie hätten
wir haben keine Wahl
von einem ernsthaften bemühen
Prioritäten zu setzen kann ich jetzt
hier bei dem Metall nicht ausgehen auch
den gesamt Etat nicht im Gegenteil
insgesamt schafft es die Ampel wirklich
in dem ersten jahrzehntausend
zusätzliche Stellen und ganz ehrlich
dieses Angebot jetzt 1,5 1,6% Stellen zu
streichen gleichen diese 10.000 zum Teil
teure Stellen nicht ansatzweise aus in
dieser Zeit wo jeder sparen muss 10.000
zusätzliche Stellen in dieser Situation
des Bürgergeld hier mehrheitlich
beschlossen wir suchen alle Hände Ringen
Leute egal wo Gastro Handwerk verkauft
Pflege also man müsste Anreise setzen
mehr Arbeit lohnt sich mehr Menschen in
Arbeit dass wir das richtige hier und
das machen wir das Bürgergeld das
Gegenteil würde hier mehrheitlich
beschlossen den ersten halben Jahr fast
keine Sanktionen bei einer Familie bis
150.000 schon Vermögen völlig falsches
Signal zum Glück zum Glück sage ich mal
haben die unionsregierten Länder des
Bundesrat gestoppt sind ja selbst die
Grünen in den Regierungen dabei
offensichtlich ist man da näher an den
Menschen und stellt sich die Frage wie
müssen das die Menschen empfinden die
nämlich das alles finanzieren und die
auch nicht viel mehr haben und die sich
abhackern und die auch Kinder erziehen
nebenher und die auch oft am Limit sind
und die auch ihre Gesundheit riskieren
auch das ist zur Wahrung des
gesamtgesellschaftlichen Friedens
wichtig und an die haben sie nämlich
nicht gedacht und deshalb ist der
Kompromiss jetzt da zum Glück kommt
natürlich ein inflationsbedingter
Ausgleich für die Hartz IV Empfänger
völlig richtig aber auch klar ist
fördern und fördern und dabei muss es
bleiben und das schlimmste wurde zum
Glück verhindern
wie gesagt mehr Anreize müssen es geben
in die Arbeit zu gehen die Menschen zu
motivieren wir haben in der
Bereinigungssitzung zahlreiche Anträge
da eingebracht wie das geht zum Beispiel
durch attraktivere Arbeitsbedingungen
für ältere Beschäftigte um die länger in
Betrieb zu halten Aufbau digitale
Angebote um die Ausbildungsplätze gerade
für die jungen Leute besser zu
koordinieren und natürlich auch ein
inklusives Digitalpaket für berufliche
Bildung auch Menschen mit Handicaps sind
wertvoll die können super Online Shops
auch machen und unseren Arbeitsmarkt
bereichern alles was geht wir haben
gesagt wir wollen eine wöchentliche
Höchstarbeitszeit den er da Bremsen wir
die Leute aus die mehr leisten wollen
darum geht es das Signal wir können aus
dieser Krise raus wir können unseren
Wohlstand auch erhalten aber jeden muss
klar sein nur wenn wir anpacken die Arme
hochkrempeln bereits in mehr zu arbeiten
und nicht den Leuten zu suggerieren ja
ja wir bezahlen euch schon eure Nachteil
diese Rechnung wird nicht aufgehen
viele Menschen in diesem Land werden
Ihren lieben dieses Jahr zu Weihnachten
weniger schenken können bitte liebe
Vertreter der Ampelkoalition treffen
auch sie zumindest im nächsten Haushalt
für diesen ist schon zu spät die
richtige Wahl beim Bestücken des
gabentisches nicht nur Symptombehandlung
Ursachenbekämpfung Angebot erhöhen
ideologieoffen ist hilft nichts anderes
und von diesen Geschenken haben die
Menschen wirklich länger etwas
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion
Katrin Michel
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Minister Hubertus Heil
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
chestioniklinie
wir befinden uns in herausfordernden
Zeiten komplexe Krisen die sich global
überlappen stellen und sie Gesellschaft
vor immense Herausforderung und umso
mehr ist dieser Haushalt ein echter
Erfolg
mein Dank ist allen Beteiligten
Mitarbeitenden und ganz besonders der
parlamentarischen Staatssekretärin
Kerstin Griese sie hat in den letzten
Wochen quasi 24/7 für uns Bericht
erstatten immer
für uns gestanden sie war jederzeit
ansprechbar und das wollte ich heute
nicht unerwähnt lassen
dem heute vorgelegten Haushalt 2023 ging
sehr intensive Verhandlungen voraus eins
war uns haushälteren wichtig nämlich
darzustellen wie wichtig und wie
kraftvoll das parlamentarische Verfahren
ist und was wir Abgeordnete letztendlich
bewirken können und es gibt sie wirklich
die Abgeordneten die mit Herzblut die
mit Sachverstand und viel Verantwortung
bis an das andere ihrer Kräfte oft
streiten und verhandeln
und es gibt die anderen
mit großen Verantwortungsbewusstsein
haben wir einen Haushalt aufgestellt der
sich wirklich sehen lassen kann der
Einzelplan elf quasi das Mutterschiff
des Haushalts bildet auch 2023 mit
166,2 Milliarden Euro den größten
einzeletat und macht etwa ein Drittel
des Gesamthaushalts aus
es ist uns gelungen den
Regierungsentwurf im parlamentarischen
Verfahren durch Anpassen von
Pflichtleistungen aufgrund der
Wirtschaftsprognosen noch einmal um 2,9
Milliarden Euro zu erhöhen so sorgen wir
auch im kommenden Jahr für ein gut
ausgestatteten und starken Sozialstaat
auf den sich die Menschen verlassen
können
Zusammenhalt in der zweiten Wende
bedeutet dass wir gerade in Krisenzeiten
in den Sozialstaat investieren und
wohlüberlegte Ausgaben für die soziale
Sicherung und ein stabilen Arbeitsmarkt
tätigen
gegenüber dem Regierungsentwurf zum
Haushalt 2023 stellen wir den Jobcentern
zusätzlich 500 Millionen Euro für
Eingliederungsleistungen und die
Verwaltung zur Verfügung das ist ein
bedeutendes Plus von dem viele Menschen
in unserem Land profitieren werden
weiterhin ist es uns gelungen die
Regelung zur Inanspruchnahme von
ausgaberesten beim Eingliederungstitel
in Höhe von bis zu 600 Millionen Euro zu
verstehen mit den insgesamt 10,3
Milliarden Euro sind die Jobcenter fürs
kommende Jahr gut aufgestellt das gibt
Perspektive das gibt Planungssicherheit
in unsicheren Zeiten und es ist ein
wesentlicher Beitrag zur Umsetzung des
Bürgergeldes
mit den zwei 10,3 Milliarden Euro
ermöglichen wir genau den
Paradigmenwechsel für den wir als SPD
schon so lange gekämpft haben diejenigen
in unserer Gesellschaft die aus
unterschiedlichen Gründen nicht in der
Lage sind eigenständig auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt Fuß zu fassen werden durch
Support der Jobcenter dabei unterstützt
ein Berufsabschluss zu machen und
bekommen so die Chance langfristig und
nachhaltig auf dem Arbeitsmarkt bestehen
zu können
und das liebe Union ist das wirkliche
Herzstück der bürgergeldreform und dafür
sind die 10,3 Milliarden gut investiert
und helfen unser Volkswirtschaft dabei
dem Fachkräftemangel entgegen zu wirken
wir müssen den veränderten
Rahmenbedingungen auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
Rechnung tragen alles andere wäre
kurzsichtig und schlicht
unverantwortlich
unverantwortlich ist leider auch das
Bild dass sie liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus den Reihen der Union in den
vergangenen Wochen mit Blick auf die
Menschen bemühen die Leistungen aus dem
SGB II beziehen
ob es der von Ihnen gesetzte Fokus auf
Sanktionsmechanismen ist
rund 97 Prozent der
Leistungsberechtigten bleiben davon
unberührt dass das wissen wir alle
schlimme aber noch finde ich diese
unsägliche neiddebacke mit Debatte die
auch vorhin Kollegin launert noch mal
bedient hat einen Neiddebatte in der sie
geringverdienende gegen Arbeitslose
ausspielen das ist schäbig und das passt
in meinen Augen so gar nicht in ein Bild
einer christlichen Partei
wir gehen mit den Bürgergeld den
zugewandten Weg wir schenken Vertrauen
und sorgen zugleich dafür dass
Anstrengung belohnt wird der
Kompromissvorschlag aus dem
Vermittlungsausschuss der Morgen zur
Abstimmung steht behält den Kern unserer
Geldreform einen echten Kulturwandel in
der Arbeitsmarktpolitik bei er ist ein
Erfolg für uns ab
1.1.2023 kommt das neue Bürgergeld
mit dem heute die patientenhaushalt
setzen wir weitere Vorhaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag um wir starten das
Bundesprogramm Barrierefreiheit um
unsere Vorhaben für mehr Inklusion und
Teilhabe im Alltag voranzutreiben wir
bauen die erfolgreiche Beratungsarbeit
der bundesfachstelle Barrierefreiheit
und der Überwachungsstelle barrierefreie
it aus und stellen den
partizipationsfonds zur Förderung von
selbstvertretungsorganisationen von
Menschen mit Behinderung rund 40 Prozent
mehr Mittel zur Verfügung
und wir haben die Errichtung einer
Stiftung zur Umsetzung des
härtefallfonds auf den Weg gebracht
endlich buchstäblich in letzter Sekunde
und gerade noch rechtzeitig und nun
können wir den betroffenen Menschen
denen unter anderem vor Hintergrund der
rentenüberleitung erhebliche Nachteile
entstanden sind und die gleichzeitig
eine sehr niedrige Rente beziehen eine
finanzielle Kompensation zukommen zu
lassen
ich appelliere an dieser Stelle erneut
und nachdrücklich an die Länder und ganz
besonders auch an mein Bundesland in
Sachsen folgen Sie dem guten Beispiel
des Bundes folgen Sie dem Bundesland
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern treten sie der
Stiftung bei und verdoppeln Sie den
Beitrag des Bundes für die in ihrem Land
lebenden Betroffenen zeigen sie endlich
Respekt
herzlichen Dank und auch
Katrin Michel war das die
Berichterstatterin der SPD es geht um
den Einzelplan 11 Arbeit und Soziales
der größte Einzelposten mit
166,23 Milliarden Euro mehr als ein
Drittel des gesamten etatars von
Christian Lindner so Ulrike Schielke sie
sind jetzt für die AFD
ein zwar weg es ist gerade einmal zwei
Wochen her da standen wir hier und
debattierten über das sogenannte
Bürgergeld ich war gerade zu entsetzt
über diesen Tiefpunkt der Debattenkultur
solche Beschimpfungen mit denen sie die
Einwände der Opposition abgebügelt haben
die gehören nicht hier hin
aber diese dünhaltigkeit zeigte auch mit
der massiven Kritik die ja nicht nur von
den Verbänden und den Bundesrechnungshof
kam nein auch von der Basis ihrer
Parteien damit haben sie nicht gerechnet
nur so ist die Erleichterung zu erklären
mit der sie sich sozusagen
gezwungenermaßen von einigen der
gröbsten Schnitzer verabschieden dürfen
doch das was übrig bleibt ist leider
kaum besser es bleibt dabei das
Bürgergeld ist kontraproduktiv es lädt
zu Missbrauch ein und ist ein Schlag ins
Gesicht derjenigen die jeden Morgen
aufstehen um sich ja Einkommen selbst zu
erarbeiten
noch schlimmer es erhöht die Gefahr
drastisch dass Menschen in die
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit landen und dort
bleiben wer das bestreitet hat lange
nicht mehr Mitarbeiter in der Jobcenter
gesprochen und das in einer Zeit in der
es kaum etwas Wichtigeres gibt als so
viele Menschen wie möglich in Arbeit zu
bringen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen heute
sprechen wir aber darüber was das alles
kostet und wie das finanziert werden
soll und siehe da wurden Gesetzesentwurf
noch 4,8 Milliarden Euro veranschlagt
werden finden sich im Einzelplan 11 nur
noch rund 3 schon die Heizkosten müssen
sie auch aus dem 60er finanzieren und
das im ersten Jahr der Einführung was
kommt danach schaffen sie das Bürgergeld
dann wieder ab wenn die Einnahmen
wegbrechen so wie das ja jetzt absehbar
ist wir stehen ja bekanntlich am Anfang
einer schweren Rezession und einer Welle
von Firmeninsolvenzen viele Menschen
werden ihre Arbeit verlieren die
Inflation steigt weiter und damit auch
die Kosten für die Lebenshaltung wer das
nicht mehr stemmen kann landet bald im
Sozialsystem und das alles muss in
Zukunft auch bezahlt werden und ich
frage mich allmählich wovon
die Ampel regiert nach dem Motto pi mal
Daumen nach Kassenlage und hofft mit
geschlossenen Augen auf das beste all
das erinnert an die Grundrente dort
wurden ja eigentlich auch ein richtiges
Anliegen nämlich die Erhöhung der Mittel
für sozialbedürftige ideologisch
überfrachtet und entgegen aller Vernunft
ins Gegenteil verkehrt auch die
Grundrente war ein Prestige-Objekt von
Herrn Heil aber um Herrn Harbeck zu
zitieren es ist ja nur Geld eine
geradezu metaphysische Einstellung die
erklärt mit welcher Großzügigkeit mit
dem Geld der Steuerzahler umgegangen
wird die Ampel hat sich bereits im
ersten Jahr ihrer Regierung mit rund 550
Milliarden verschuldet nicht genug im
Schatten daneben türmen sich und für 28
kreativ betitelte Sondervermögen für
dies und das in Milliarden Höhe Schulden
die nicht im Bundeshaushalt auftauchen
die Arbeit zurückgezahlt werden müssen
von unseren Kindern und Enkeln und seit
neuestem auch für die aktienrente
grundsätzlich ist es richtig über eine
langfristige Ergänzung der diese
Finanzierung in der Rentenversicherung
nachzudenken aber so zu tun als ob man
mit einem Anschub von 10 Milliarden Euro
die Rentenversicherung Demografie
festmachen könnte ist lächerlich zum
Vergleich das Volumen der gesetzlichen
Rentenversicherung beträgt schon heute
rund 330 Milliarden Euro pro Jahr ein
Drittel davon sind Steuerzuschüsse daran
gemessen ist die Summe um die es hier
geht nicht mal ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein
für einen nennenswerten Effekt müsste
man also einen weit höheren Betrag und
zwar jährlich als feste Ausgabe
einplanen wenn man das Geld dann hätte
stattdessen muss sogar der Einschub von
10 Milliarden Euro auf kreditfinanziert
werden Herr Lindner zockt also mit der
Erwartung dass die Erträge dieser
Kapitalanlagen langfristig die Kosten
übersteigen die er wegen steigender
Zinsen dafür zahlen muss das ist
gefährlich die Alternative ist dagegen
unbequem Umsteuern und sparen was das
Zeug hält sämtliche Ausgaben müssen auf
den Prüfstand unter der Vorgabe was ist
wirklich notwendig und sinnvoll was
brauchen wir um die wirtschaftlichen
Grundlagen des Landes zu sichern und
wovon müssen wir uns verabschieden liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nichts davon
ist zu erkennen nichts davon ist gewollt
und das ist beängstigend denn es schadet
unserem Land dauerhaft
denn so werden weiterhin Milliarden für
ideologischen Unsinn versenkt während am
anderen Ende das Geld fehlt zum Beispiel
für die angemessene Ausstattung das
härtefallfonds das betrifft
hunderttausende ost-rentner die vielfach
in Armut leben weil ihnen bekanntlich
durch Verfahrensfehler bei der
Überleitung ins westdeutsche Rentenrecht
ein Teil ihrer Rente genommen wurde die
angedachte Lösung bleibt finanziell weit
hinter den berechtigten Erwartungen
zurück sogar ihr SPD-Kollege dulig
bezeichnete sie als Zitat politischen
Kompromiss auf kleinstem gemeinsamen
Nenner das ist zu wenig das hilft nicht
und das ist den Menschen die so lange
auf Unterstützung warten nicht
angemessen deshalb appelliere ich an sie
vergrößern Sie diesen gemeinsamen Nenner
tun Sie was richtig ist für andere Dinge
ist ja anscheinend auch Geld da vielen
Dank
der nächste Redner in der Debatte über
den Etat des bundesarbeitsministers
Hubertus Heil kommt von den
Bündnisgrünen Markus Kurt er ist der
Berichterstatter für seine Fraktion
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
Kolleginnen dr launert meine Kollegen
von der cdu/csu-fraktion gerne hätte ich
jetzt hier von dieser Stelle aus über
die Höhe des eingliederungstitels zur
Förderung von Langzeitarbeitslosen
diskutiert ob der ausreicht oder nicht
wir haben ja immerhin 500 Millionen
wieder reingeholt gerne hätte ich über
Zahlen diskutiert auch zur
berufsbezogenen Sprachförderung und
dergleichen aber was muss ich mir hier
stattdessen anhören wieder werden
Langzeitarbeitslose oder Menschen die
etwa weil sie alleinerziehend sind und
deswegen im Arbeitslosengeld zwei landen
diffamiert und als Projektionsfläche
missbraucht für Risse und die Mond night
und Missgunst
wieder muss ich mir hier anhören wie sie
Mindestlohn beziehende
instrumentalisieren denn nichts anderes
tun sie um ein Differenzen herzustellen
und sie werden auch den arbeitenden in
diesem Bereich überhaupt nicht gerecht
damit denn Arbeit ist mehr als Geld
Arbeit ist Teilhabe und bedeutet
Austausch und soziale und auch
gesundheitliche Stabilität wenn es nur
um das Kalkül ginge
wenn es nur um das Finanzielle Kalkül
gegen dürfte es ja gar keine arbeitenden
Menschen geben die auf einen Anspruch
auf ergänzendes Arbeitslosengeld 2
verzichten die sogenannte verdeckte
Armut das zeigt doch wie viele Menschen
stolz sind dass sie ihre Arbeit haben
die gar nicht angewiesen sein wollen auf
das Jobcenter und auf Kosten dieser
Menschen Politik zu machen ist unerhört
und wenn sie und wenn sie den
Mindestlohn beziehen dann wirklich
gerecht werden wollen und den
geringverdienenden dann tun Sie etwas
zur Stärkung etwa von Tarifbindung und
Tariftreue das wäre dann der ehrliche
Ansatz an der Stelle
und stattdessen arbeiten sie mit
falschen Zahlen was sie auch am Ende
zugegeben haben und der Kollege Jens
Spahn wird von der taz am 20.11
interviewt und ihm wird das vorgehalten
mit den falschen Zahlen Antwort Jens
Spahn standen in der taz noch die
falsche Zahlen das spricht doch wohl für
sich dieser Antwort standen da noch nie
falsche Zahlen aber die Interviewerin
gibt Jens Spahn noch eine zweite Chance
stellt die Frage wäre da nicht eine
Entschuldigung angesagt Antwort Jens
Spahn es geht um die Frage ob sich
arbeiten lohnt oder nicht diese Debatten
müssen wir führen das finde ich wirklich
unerhört sie hätten da klatschen sie
auch noch da klatschen sie auch noch es
ist ja noch nicht mal der Versuch von
Jens Spahn an dieser Stelle zu verhehlen
das falsche Zahlen zu Kampagnenführung
verwendet worden sind
und wenn
und wenn man daneben noch die Äußerungen
legt des bayerischen Ministerpräsidenten
der dann gesagt hat wenn Video gehen ist
Foul in der Tonne liegt der kriegt keine
Leistung und das Ganze vor dem Grillen
im bierzeltpublikum von sich gegeben hat
wenn man das zusammenlegt dann sieht man
dass dieser Ansatz Spaltung als
politisches Geschäftsmodell ist
und welche Geister wecken Sie welche
Geister sie wecken das konnten sie
gerade hier in der Rede von Frau
Schielke sie singen hören und in vielen
anderen Sachen auch nachlesen und hören
und ich sage Ihnen bevor sie sich so
aufregen aus der Union ich will diese
Spaltung nicht ich möchte das bewusst
nicht nein deswegen werde ich sie auch
nicht pauschal verteufeln oder gar in
die Nähe der AFD Stellen ich weiß
nämlich dass es bei ihnen Menschen gibt
die das besser wissen Hermann Gröhe will
ich nennen Karl Josef Laumann
stellvertretend von einem halben Jahr
war ich beim Jobcenter Münster
kommunales Jobcenter der jobcenterleiter
CDU-Mitglied ist mit mir und der
Sozialdezernent in dort den
Koalitionsvertrag durchgegangen und fand
das nicht alles aber überwiegend
vernünftig vor allen Dingen fand er den
Ansatz vernünftig eine Vertrauensbasis
ist aufzubauen um dann Motivation und
Befähigung zu schaffen diesen
Grundeinsatz fand er völlig richtig und
er sagt mir sinn das machen wir hier in
Münster schon sowieso und das
das sind Personen
aus der Union die mir die Hoffnung geben
dass wir zum rationalen und vernünftigen
Diskurs an der Stelle führen kommen und
es gibt doch Hoffnung und das ist eben
der Ansatz den wir dann auch versuchen
im Haushalt wiederum abzubilden die
Haltung die sich im morgen zu
verabschiedenen bürgergeldgesetz
wiederfindet aber eben auch die
finanzielle Hinterlegung die wir machen
und wir sehen auch die Vielfalt der
verschiedenen Problemlagen die im
Sozialgesetzbuch zwei oder im
Bürgerrecht sind es handelt sich ja
keineswegs überwiegend um
Langzeitarbeitslose sondern um Kinder
und Jugendlichen sehr großen Teil
Alleinerziehende es geht um Menschen die
vielleicht aus gesundheitlichen Gründen
Beeinträchtigungen haben es geht um
Aufstocker es geht um eine ganze
Vielfalt des Lebens und diese Vielfalt
des Lebens die muss man im Umgang mit
Personen die auch Unterstützung
angewiesen sind abbilden die Zahlen sind
das einer das dürre was sozusagen
auf dem Papier steht und das andere ist
die Haltung mit mehr mit der man diese
Zahlen mit Leben erfüllt
und das ist am Ende auch
Wirtschaftspolitik wir haben nämlich
eine ganz andere Situation als zu der
Zeit als das SGB II ich war selbst dabei
ins Leben gerufen wurde wir haben jetzt
keine Massenarbeitslosigkeit sondern wir
haben einen Arbeitskräftemangel nicht
nur facharbeitskräfte Mangel sondern
Arbeitskräftemangel und es geht darum
die Potenziale nicht nur aus
menschlichen Gründen sondern auch aus
wirtschaftlichen Gründen die Potenziale
zu heben diese großartigen Potenziale
die wir in diesem Land mit allen
Menschen haben ist das niemand verloren
gehen und das ist unser Ansatz vielen
Dank
und in dieser ersten Runde zum
einzelbahn 11-arbeit und Soziales hat
jetzt für die Linke die
stellvertretende Fraktionsvorsitzende
gesehene Lötsch das Wort ist die
Berichterstatterin und sie gehört auch
zum Vermittlungsausschuss der gestern
Abend das Bürgergeld durchgehen hat
und Grüne unter aktiver Mitwirkung von
Union und FDP die harzgesetze eingeführt
wir haben damals gesagt Hartz IV ist
Armut per Gesetz das hat sich leider
bewahrheitet und darum brauchen wir
einen grundlegenden Systemwechsel meine
Damen und Herren
ich verstehe dass die hartz-iv-parteien
ihr Hartz IV mit Schluss werden wollen
das Bürgergeld enthält einige
Verbesserungen und darum haben wir im
Bundestag das Gesetz auch nicht
abgelehnt doch das Vermittlungsverfahren
hat das Gesetz nicht besser sondern
schlechter gemacht und das ist schade
meine Damen und Herren der damalige
Bundeskanzler Gerhard Schröder SPD sagte
stolz wir haben den größten
Niedriglohnsektor Europas geschaffen ich
finde das eine fatale Aussage eine
Million Menschen die einer regelmäßigen
Arbeit nachgehen müssen aufstocken
welche Demütigung so darf das nicht
weitergehen
was wir brauchen sind deutlich höhere
Löhne und eine effektive Kontrolle der
Einhaltung des Mindestlohnes alles
andere ist lohndruckerei meine Damen und
Herren von Union und FDP merken Sie sich
das
die Erhöhung der Regelsätze ist
überfällig bei Preissteigerung von
Grundnahrungsmitteln von 20 Prozent in
einem Jahr sind 53 € mehr Hartz 4 im
Monat eben kein ausreichender
Inflationsausgleich der Paritätische
Wohlfahrtsverband hat neu berechnet und
fordert ein Regelsatz von 725 € pro
Monat über diese Forderung sollten wir
alle gemeinsam nachdenken meine Damen
und Herren und sie unterstützen
bei den Sanktionen hat die Ampel schnell
eine Rolle rückwärts gemacht die
Regierung mag offensichtlich Sanktionen
allerdings nicht bei allen wenn es
nämlich um Einkommensmillionäre geht die
bei der steuerbetrügen da sind sie sehr
großzügig der Bundesrechnungshof hat
bereits im Jahr 2006 bemängelt das
Einkommensmillionäre zu selten geprüft
werden die Prüfquote ist in den
vergangenen Jahren nicht gestiegen
sondern gesunken und das ist fatal meine
Damen und Herren der Chef ist die Idee
rechnet uns vor dass der Schaden durch
Steuerhinterziehung pro Jahr 100
Milliarden Euro beträgt der Schaden
durch Hartz IV betrug macht 60 Millionen
Euro aus mit diesem Missverhältnis haben
die Hartz iv-parteien offensichtlich
kein Problem meine Damen und Herren es
ist beängstigend wie die schmächtige FDP
knallhart die Interessen der Vermögen in
dieser Koalition durchsetzt gehen Sie
auf einen anderen Weg meine Damen und
Herren von SPD grün ansonsten landen sie
in der Ecke der FDP das kann doch nicht
ihr Ziel sein herzlichen Dank
Gesine lütsch von der Linksfraktion war
das und weiter geht's mit der FDP
Claudia Raffel und auch sie ist die
Berichterstatterin für den Bereich
Arbeit und Soziales für ihre Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin lieber
Minister Hubertus Heil liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen die Aufstellung des
Arbeits- und
Sozialetats Entschuldigung in diesem
Jahr war besonders anspruchsvoll Corona
keine Krieg und Energiekrise all das
tangiert insbesondere den Einzelplan 11
wir haben einen soliden
Regierungsentwurf in den letzten Wochen
noch weiter konsolidieren können denn
die Frage wie wir das zur Verfügung
stehende Geld noch besser verausgaben
können bleibt ein wichtiger Grundsatz
und zwar immer nicht nur in Krisenzeiten
absolut klar war für uns deshalb dass
alle Änderungen die wir als Koalition im
Regierungsentwurf vornehmen im eigenen
Etat gegenfinanziert sind so gewähren
wir jetzt der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
und den Jobcentern mehr Spielraum im
Bereich der Eingliederung und
kompensieren hier einmalig im
Haushaltsjahr 2023 und aufgrund des
entstehenden
Wechsel der Ukraine geflüchteten über
das Bürgergeld das ist sachlogisch denn
wir setzen hiermit einen Anreiz zu mehr
aktiv statt passivleistung
selbstverständlich
selbstverständlich bleibt es bei unserem
Grundsatz arbeit muss sich lohne deshalb
gilt es diejenigen zu unterstützen die
aus dem Ausland in unseren Arbeitsmarkt
hinzukommen sich fort und weiterbilden
wollen oder keine Chance auf berufliche
Qualifikation bisher hatten im
Gesamtbudget SGB II stehen den
Jobcentern unter Einbezug aller
Ausgabeposten nun
10,35 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung hier
haben wir also deutlich verstärkt und
den Hilferufen aus den Jobcentern
[Applaus]
mehr Menschen in Arbeit zu bringen muss
unser Hauptziel sein und bleiben denn
wir entlasten damit darüber hinaus auch
unsere Sozialversicherungssysteme
außerdem starten wir es Bundesprogramm
Barrierefreiheit mit zwei Millionen Euro
Anstoß Finanzierung für mehr Teilhabe
für mehr Teilhabe beeinträchtigt der
Menschen am gesellschaftlichen Leben
pünktlich zum Internationalen Tag der
Menschen mit Behinderung am dritten
Dezember setzen wir ein Zeichen und
ermöglichen dass die mit dem Programm
verbundene Maßnahmen in 2023 pünktlich
starten können
da wir Haushaltspolitiker unsere Arbeit
als Hüter des Gesetzes als Hüter des
Geldes
freut ernst nehmen haben wir die
Ausgaben gesperrt bis uns ein Konzept
über die konkrete Ausgestaltung der
Bundesinitiative vorgelegt wird wir
wollen zu sicherstellen dass das
zusätzliche Geld auch wirklich Sache
erreicht verausgabt wird darüber hinaus
stärken wir die nationale
Armutskonferenz den sogenannten
partizipationsform in den bisherigen
Förderentscheidungen
in den bisherigen Förderentscheidung
konnten aufgrund der knappen
Mittelausstattung nicht alle Anträge
bewilligt werden etwa aus dem Bereich
der Gehörlosen Community mit den
zusätzlichen Mitteln sollen nunmehr
Spielraum geschaffen werden um weitere
Projekte fördern zu können
mit all diesen Vorhaben setzen wir
weitere zentrale Versprechen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag um und zeigen
gleichwohl das Steuergeld ein endliches
gut ist denn wir finanzieren diese aus
dem eigenen
oftmals hat der Staat leider nicht nur
ein Ausgabenproblem sondern auch ein
ausgabenstrukturproblem nicht nur über
das Wie viel sondern auch das wofür
haben wir uns gemeinsam mit dem BMAS
ausgetauscht ich bin sehr froh darüber
dass wir im Kapitel Arbeitswelt im
Wandel hier liegt der Mittelabfluss seit
Jahren deutlich unter dem veranschlagten
soll Ansatz 10 Millionen Euro zugunsten
des Bundeshaushalts kürzen konnten
Koalition und BMAS setzen damit ein
gemeinsames Zeichen wo Geld nicht
gebraucht wird setzen wir es frei
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
natürlich bleibt ein zentraler
krisenherz des Einzelplans die Rente
denn die Zukunftsfähigkeit unserer
Rentenversicherung hat höchste Priorität
ich freue mich deshalb wirklich über den
Einstieg in ein Kapital gedecktes System
mit dem mit dem Renteneintritt der
Babyboomer ab dem Jahr 2025 werden
unsere Rentenkassen jedoch unter noch
massiveren Drucker an sie haben weniger
Kinder geboren sind jedoch selbst viele
die Rentenversicherung sieht sich also
bald mit immer weniger Einzahlern und
immer mehr Empfängern konfrontiert
dieser demografische Effekt wird noch
eklatanter wenn wir die steigende
Lebenserwartung hinzuziehen und die
Rente somit immer länger bezogen wird
die fünf großen rentenzuschüsse betragen
im Jahr
2023 zusammen
106,6 Milliarden Euro hier ist etwas aus
dem Fugen geraten und es braucht nun
dringend sanfte Impulse an den
Stellschrauben der Rente und mehr
Flexibilität beim Renten Eintrittsalter
denn selbstverständlich sollte ein
Dachdecker nicht mit 60 Jahren noch
weiter arbeiten andere Berufsgruppen
könnten und wollten das aber durchaus
leider hat es bisher fast fast keine
Regierung geschafft im Rentensystem eine
Therapie zu verabreichen wir machen das
anders und denken langfristig für unsere
Kinder und Enkelkinder
genau 10 Milliarden Euro Kapitalstock
sind ein Lichtblick ein guter Anfang und
ein sehr gutes Signal für unsere Jugend
eine Notoperation an unserem eigentliche
umlagefinanzierten System ersetzen sie
jedoch nicht lieber Herr Minister ich
würde mich über einen gemeinsamen
Aufbruch freuen lassen sie uns hierbei
oder hierzu zu dem Thema immer im
Gespräch bleiben
abschließend noch eine Erfolgsmeldung es
geht um den Fonds zur Abmilderung von
Härtefällen in der rentenüberleitung für
Spätaussiedler und jüdische Zuwanderer
der im Bundeshaushalt 2032 jetzt nicht
mehr etatisiert ist für das aktuelle
laufende Haushaltsjahr stehen 500
Millionen Euro zur Verfügung die mit
einer Sperre versehen war
ursprünglich sollte das formvolumen von
dem Bundesländern und den gleichen
Betrag ergänzt werden hier wurde eine
gemeinschaftliche Beteiligung seitens
der Länder aber abgelehnt das ist aus
mehreren Gründen wirklich zynisch denn
erstens wurde im Bundesrat oft und
vehement angemahnt dass mehr für die
beschriebenen Bedarfsgruppen getan
werden muss
zweitens sprechen wir hier bei Menschen
im fortgeschrittenen Alter die eine
Entschädigung nicht nur aus finanziellen
sondern eben auch aus symbolischen
Gründen mehr als verdient hätten und
drittens weisen die Länder gegenüber dem
Bund ein deutlichen einnahme- bzw
Haushalt zu Überschuss aus als
Ampelkoalition haben wir die Sperre in
der vergangenen Sitzung des
Haushaltsausschusses aufgehoben so dass
der Bundesanteil nun bald an die
Anspruchsberechtigten ausgezahlt werden
kann
der Bund wird die möglichen Ausfall der
heftigen Beteiligung durch die
Bundesländer jedoch nicht kompensieren
und das ist richtig liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen wie sagte schon Hans
Dietrich Genscher liberale Wissen
verantwortliche Politik muss der
Freiheit und der würde jedes einzelne
Menschen dienen aber Freiheit und
Verantwortung gehören für uns lieberale
untrennbar zusammen daher gilt wir sind
für die Menschen in diesem Land da wir
lassen niemanden alleine gleichwohl gilt
aber auch wir haben eine große
Verantwortung für die zukünftigen
Generation sind unsere Kinder und unsere
Enkelkinder und ihnen wollen wir
hoffentlich alle ein solideren Staat
hinterlassen ich danke Ihnen
war das für die FDP der nächste
renal-kom von der cdu/csu Stefan Stracke
er Sprecher für Arbeit und Soziales der
unions
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren der
Vermittlungsausschuss hat gestern den
Weg frei gemacht für die
Weiterentwicklung von Hartz IV und
voraussichtlich werden wir ja am Freitag
darüber auch hier im Deutschen Bundestag
beschließen wir werden als
Unionsfraktion diesen Gesetzesentwurf
zustimmen und entscheidend und wichtig
für uns insbesondere die Anpassung der
Regelsätze an die hohen Teuerungsraten
die schnelle Anpassung stand dabei nie
im politischen Streit wir sorgen jetzt
für Sicherheit für diejenigen die darauf
angewiesen sind das ist notwendig und
richtig meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren dass wir das tun
das Arbeitslosengeld 2 landläufig Jahre
Hartz IV genannt sichert Menschen in
existenzieller not verlässlich ab und
entscheidend ist gerade in der jetzigen
Situation dass ich Arbeitslosigkeit
nicht verfestigt dass aus
Arbeitslosigkeit nicht
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit entsteht und
dass wir diejenige die auf Hilfe
angewiesen sind dazu befähigen
ertüchtigen und ermutigen doch auf diese
Hilfe zu verzichten dass sie wieder
selber möglichst schnell und dauerhaft
wieder in Arbeit kommen und da waren wir
in den letzten 16 Jahren unsere
Regierungszeit sehr erfolgreich darin
über 2,2 Millionen Menschen haben wir
zurückgebracht in Arbeit haben es
geschafft dass sie ein festen Platz in
der Arbeitsgesellschaft haben ist ein
großer Erfolg der natürlich mit Hartz IV
in diesem Bereich intensiv zusammenhält
ob die Voraussetzungen dass ein solcher
Erfolg auch jetzt wieder gelingen kann
sind so gut wie nie zuvor 1,9 Millionen
Stellen sind offen viele davon sind
fachkräftestellen aber natürlich auch
arbeitskräftestellen und wir müssen
jetzt alles dafür tun dass der Weg aus
der Arbeitslosigkeit zurück in Arbeit
gelingt denn klar ist Arbeit ist viel
mehr als bloßer Broterwerb er hat vor
allem mit
Anerkennung mit Selbstwertgefühl und mit
Teilhabe zu tun und deswegen war es uns
so wichtig dass das Grundprinzip fördern
und fordern auch weiterhin geht und zwar
vom ersten Tag an intensiv sich mit dem
einzelnen auseinanderzusetzen zu sehen
wo seine Problemlagen sind in so
motivieren und zu aktivieren und dazu
gehört eben auch dass man
Eigenbemühungen
Mitwirkungspflichten verbindlich
einfordern kann das ist auch ein Gebot
der Fairness gegenüber dem Steuerzahler
der mit seinen Steuermitteln dafür sorgt
dass dieses System auch finanziert ist
und funktioniert und deswegen
haben wir als Union dafür gesorgt dass
es zu keinem Systemwechsel kommt so wie
er im Gesetzesentwurf ja ursprünglich
auch beabsichtigt war ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen kommt
nicht und das ist auch die entscheidende
Veränderung die wir durchgesetzt haben
dass vom ersten Tag an nicht nur melde
Versäumnisse entsprechend geahndet
werden können sondern auch
Pflichtverletzungen und deswegen
und deswegen gilt
die Schonzeit von einem halben Jahr es
vom Tisch der Freischuss bei
Pflichtverletzungen ist vom Tisch und
dies gilt alles dann auch zum ersten
Januar des nächsten Jahres wenn die
Zustimmung dann am Freitag erfolgen wird
von diesem Hohen Haus denn der
sanktionsmonatorium wird auch frühzeitig
beendet nämlich zum ersten Januar auch
das ist ein richtiger Erfolg denn das
Grundprinzip fördern und fördern muss
gelten von Tag ein am Tag eins an
wir verändern auch noch mals die Regeln
was die Karenzzeit angeht ein Jahr statt
zwei Jahre der Schonvermögen wird
erheblich reduziert alles andere wäre
auch überhaupt nicht vermittelbar
gewesen gegen dem gegenüber der mit
einem kleinen Einkommen beispielsweise
und mit seinen Steuermitteln dafür sorgt
dass derjenige dann Leistungen bezieht
obwohl er diese in dieser Form auch gar
nicht notwendig hat das hat etwas mit
Nachhaltigkeit und dem Nachgang
Grundsatz in diesem Bereich zu tun
ja erlauben sie eine Zwischenfrage oder
Bemerkung aus der SPD-Fraktion ja er hat
sich gerne bitte schön
Herr Stracke es freut mich ja zu hören
dass ihre Fraktion dem Gesetz jetzt am
Ende voraussichtlich zustimmen wird
bezüglich des Kompromisses den sie
gerade referieren möchte ich doch
tatsächlich noch mal fragen und zwar
stellen sie ja da die Karenzzeit wird
jetzt verkürzt von zwei Jahren auf ein
Jahr das ist richtig das steht so in dem
Kompromiss sie sagen nun das sei aber
eben auch verhältnismäßig und richtig
okay ich möchte Sie fragen ist Ihnen
bekannt dass das vor allem für
diejenigen Menschen jetzt ein Problem
wird die z.B eine Qualifizierung
anstreben weil wenn man sich mal anguckt
jetzt nur 12 Monate zu haben bedeutet
eben wenn man eben den die Leistungen
beantragt dann den kooperationsplan
erarbeitet dann eine entsprechende
Qualifizierung vermittelt bekommt wenn
ihnen sechs Monate geht beispielsweise
man dann auch einen neuen Job finden
muss dass es genau die Leute sind trifft
die dann neu aus der Karenzzeit
rausfallen werden und das ist eigentlich
ein gemeinsames Anliegen war die
Weiterbildung zu stärken erste Frage
zweite Frage ist Ihnen eigentlich
bekannt sie haben ja gerade über die
Pflichtverletzung gesprochen dass die
Regelung zu den Pflichtverletzungen
gegenüber dem ursprungsgesetz ja jetzt
sogar noch mal abgemildert wurden denn
neu ist ja jetzt dass bei der ersten
Pflichtverletzung nur einen Monat mit
10% sanktioniert wurden vorher waren es
drei Monate mit 20%, also von einer
Verschärfung der Sanktion kann doch
eigentlich gar keine Rede sein sind
Ihnen diese Umstände bekannt
die Frau Kollegin vielen herzlichen Dank
für ihre beiden Fragen die ich sehr
gerne natürlich auch beantworte zum
einen was das Thema der Karenzzeit
angeht also sie haben zunächst einmal
zwei Jahre Karenzzeit vorgesehen gehabt
und ich muss sagen es ist schon ein
Übermaß an dem was notwendig ist weil
sie das auch immer vermitteln müssen
gegenüber demjenigen der mit seinen
stollenmitteln dazu beiträgt dass diese
System auch funktioniert und bezahlt
wird und deswegen ist es nicht
nachvollziehbar gegenüber demjenigen der
mit seinen
Erwerbseinkommen dazu beiträgt und wenig
Vermögen letztendlich hat dass er
diejenigen dann unterstützen soll der
beispielsweise 60.000 € auf der hohen
Kante hat und deswegen haben wir
natürlich dafür gesorgt dass dieses
schon Vermögen reduziert wird das ist
eine Frage der Gerechtigkeit und der
Nachvollziehbarkeit auf das Systems das
sie diese Fehlstellung wir in diesem
Bereich tatsächlich beseitigt haben und
wir machen damit mit diesem einen Jahr
auch die den Kopf frei für diejenigen
die beispielsweise sagen sie wollen
jetzt in die Ausbildung oder
Qualifizierung hineingehen auch dafür
sorgen wir entsprechend für
Planungssicherheit und es ist doch auch
ihre eigene Argumentation Frau Kollegin
ich darf Sie daran erinnern diese sagen
sie nehmen vor allem diejenigen in den
Blick mit der Karenzzeit die selber
möglichst schnell aus dieser
Arbeitslosigkeit herausfinden und da
haben sie selber gesagt das sind wenige
Monate bis zur rund einem Jahr und
deswegen ist es genau richtig Sie in
diesem Bereich dann festzuhalten es sind
ja die sogenannten High Performer von
den im Bereich der Grünen ja häufiger
gesprochen wird also deswegen ist es ja
richtig dass wir dann sagen wir knüpfen
das an diese an diesen Bereich an und
das zweite betrifft die Frage der
grundverletzungen also es ist schon
notwendig dass Eigenbemühungen dann auch
verlässlich eingefordert werden können
und zwar vom ersten Tag an und deswegen
haben wir dafür gesorgt dass der
kooperationsplan und die Aufforderungen
die auf den kooperationsplan Stufen mit
Rechtsverbindlichkeit versehen werden
können denn nur so können diese
letztendlich auch eingefordert werden
und es ist auch eine Frage der Fairness
dass ich dann auch sagen kann derjenige
den ich unterstütze von dem darf ich
doch auch erwarten dass er entsprechende
Eigenbemühungen hat und deswegen haben
wir dafür gesorgt dass Pflichtverletzung
vom ersten Tag an da sind und richtig
ist im Rahmen des Kompromisses haben wir
die Pflichtverletzungen noch einmal
entsprechend abgestaffelt was die
sanktionsfolge angeht aber auch im
übrigen klargestellt dass derjenige sich
ein Jahr lang auch so verhalten muss
dass es zu keinen weiteren
Pflichtverletzungen kommt wenn er
beispielsweise 30 Prozent und damit des
Maximum an Pflichtverletzungen erreicht
hat und auch das ist eine wichtige
marksignal in diesem Bereich und meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
wir bewahren das fordern und wollen beim
fördern insgesamt besser werden deswegen
ist es richtig dass jetzt bei dieser
Weiterentwicklung von Hartz IV
Ausbildung und Arbeit entsprechend
gleichgestellt werden der Rechtsrahmen
war im übrigen da in diesem Bereich nie
das Problem denn sie verweisen zwar
immer darauf dass der
vermittlungsvorrang jetzt abgeschafft
wird in ihrem eigenen Gesetzesentwurf
schreiben Sie doch ich zitiere die
bestehenden Regelungen des SGB II
formulieren keinen ausdrücklichen
vermittlungsvorgang Zitat Ende der
Rechtsrahmen war nie das Problem sondern
es ging alleine darum wie die Praxis
damit umgeht und das was die Praxis tut
zeichnen sie nun in ihrem Gesetzentwurf
nach das ist richtig und damit setzen
wir auch einen deutlichen Schwerpunkt in
diesen Bereichen sie unterstreichen das
auch noch mit mehr finanziellen Mitteln
die notwendig sind auch mit besseren
hinzuverdienstmöglich werden das ist
wichtig in dem Bereich beschreibt aber
auch die eigentliche Problemlage um die
es in diesem Bereich geht um tatsächlich
Arbeitslose zu motivieren aus der
Arbeitslosigkeit herauszukommen eine
Qualifizierung und eine Ausbildung
entsprechend auch anzugreifen diese
Zielrichtung teilen wir und das ist auch
richtig entscheidend wird allerdings
sein dass die Mittelausstattung der
Jobcenter entsprechend stattfindet all
das was sie in Schaufenster stellen muss
auch Realität in der Praxis werden und
der zeigt sich bei den
eingliederungsmitteln sie kürzen diese
von auf 4 und 400 Teil 400 Millionen
Euro kürzen Sie die eingliederungsmittel
sehr wohl und damit steht weniger Geld
zur Verfügung obwohl wir gleichzeitig
590.000 und kleineren Ukrainer mehr im
System haben die auf Unterstützung
angewiesen sind sie sorgen nicht dafür
mit der notwendigen Mittelausstattung
das was sie in das Gesetz schreiben auch
tatsächlich Realität werden muss und das
ist die Aufgabe vor der wir gemeinsam in
diesem Bereich stehen und vor allem sie
vielen herzlichen Dank
Stefan Stracke hat für die Union das
Bürgergeld hauptamtlich
mitverhandelt und das Bürgergeld es ist
und soll ja das Meisterstück von
Hubertus Heil dem Bundesarbeitsminister
werden und er hat sich gestern nach dem
Vermittlungsausschuss als Letzter vor
die Kameras gestellt und man merkte ihm
auch die Genugtuung an das Hartz 4 nun
endlich abgewickelt werden meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
die Beratung über den Haushalt des
Bundesministeriums zu arbeiten soziales
gibt mal Gelegenheit in diesen Zeiten
nicht nur Danke zu sagen den
haushälteren Haushältern die hart
gearbeitet haben sondern vor allen
Dingen mal über die Prinzipien zu reden
nach denen wir Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik in Deutschland gestalten
und das sind Zeiten von Krieg und Krise
und das sind Zeiten fundamentaler
unbrüche die Wirtschaft und Arbeitswelt
verändern was ist das Leitmotiv der
Ampelkoalition von SPD Bündnis 90 den
Grünen und FDP es ist das Motto Chancen
und Schutz denn um beides geht es meine
Damen und Herren es geht darum dass die
Qualität eines Sozialstaates sich zum
einen daran bemisst wie man mit Menschen
umgeht die auf Hilfe und Unterstützung
angewiesen sind aber die Qualität des
Sozialstaates bemisst sich nicht allein
an der Frage der Fähigkeit wie man
Menschen in Not schützen kann sondern
vor allen Dingen an der Qualität des
Sozialstaates Menschen zu einem
selbstbestimmten Leben ohne Abhängigkeit
zu befähigen und das ist der Kompass
und dabei steht für uns der Wert und die
Würde der Arbeit ganz vorne an das ist
der Grund warum die
Bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
Koalitionsfraktionen dafür gesorgt hat
dass der Mindestlohn steigt seit 1
oktober ist der Mindestlohn in
Deutschland 12 Euro das hilft 6,5
Millionen Menschen in Deutschland arbeit
muss sich lohnen meine Damen und Herren
Arbeit muss den Unterschied machen
und das ist der Grund warum diese
Bundesregierung dafür gesorgt hat mit
den Koalitionsfraktionen gemeinsam dass
wir Menschen mit geringem Einkommen bei
Steuern und Abgaben entlasten damit sie
netto mehr in der Tasche haben damit
Arbeit sich lohnt weil Arbeit in
Unterschied macht meine Damen und Herren
das ist der Grund
warum wir das Wohngeld erhöhen warum wir
auch dafür gesorgt haben dass das
Kindergeld steigt
meine Damen und Herren Arbeit ist mehr
als Brot Erwerb ich bin sehr dankbarer
Stracke dass sie mich ständig zitieren
ich werde nur dankbar dass sie ihre
Fußnoten dann auch überprüfen wenn Sie
das ständig tun wenn wir uns da doch
einig sind Arbeit ist wichtig für den
Zusammenhalt von Gesellschaft weil es
geht um Teilhabe um Kolleginnen und
Kollegen zu haben und was zu leisten und
Teil der Gesellschaft zu sein das ist
das Ziel unserer Politik wer arbeiten
will soll unterstützt werden wir
arbeiten kann muss die Chance in
Deutschland bekommen das ist das Ziel
dieser Koalition meine Damen und Herren
und frau Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren es ist richtig der
Vermittlungsausschuss hat gestern den
wir frei gemacht dass das Bürgergeld zum
1 Januar kommen wird Hartz IV wird
Geschichte sein dass Bürgergeld wird zum
ersten Januar in Kraft treten das ist
ein wesentlicher Schritt eine große
Sozialreform die wir gemeinsam stimmen
und auch dabei geht es um Chancen und
Schutz
es geht darum Menschen die Not geraten
sind verlässlich und unbürokratischer
als im Hartz-IV-System abzusichern und
das schafft dieses Gesetz
mit großen Maßnahmen
auch mit der Erhöhung des Regelsatzes
aber auch uns das ist uns nicht genug
unser Ziel bleibt wo immer es möglich
ist Menschen in Arbeit zu bringen ihnen
Chancen auf den selbstbestimmtes Leben
zu öffnen und dafür zu sorgen dass
Arbeit sich lohnt und mit dem Bürgergeld
lohnt sich Arbeit mehr wir sorgen dafür
dass beispielsweise die
Zuverdienstmöglichkeiten großzügiger
werden meine Damen und Herren Arbeit
macht den Unterschied und dabei hilft
auch das
und dieses Bürgergeld sorgt auch dafür
dass wir die Chance geben mehr
qualifizierte Fachkräfte in Deutschland
zu haben im bisherigen System im
Hartz-IV-System sind zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen Menschen ohne
jegliche Berufsausbildung im bisherigen
hartz-systemen kommen die hin und wieder
mal in Hilfsjobs und das Jobcenter sieht
sie nach ein paar Monaten wieder mit
diesen neuen Ansatz mit dem Bürgergeld
setzen wir auf Weiterbildungen
Qualifizierung wir sorgen dafür dass
Menschen ein Abschluss nachholen können
um dauerhaft am Arbeitsmarkt Fuß zu
fassen
und ja ich bin sehr froh und dankbar
dass wir es schaffen werden
voraussichtlich morgen dass der Deutsche
Bundestag in der Bundesrat diese große
soziale Reform mit großen Mehrheiten
beschließt und dazu waren harte
Gespräche und anstrengende Verhandlungen
notwendig ich möchte mich ganz herzlich
bedanken erstmal bei den
Koalitionsfraktionen die den Weg frei
gemacht haben für sozialen Fortschritte
den Bürgergeld aber ich möchte mich auch
bedanken bei den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der Union namentlich Herr
Josef Laumann aus Nordrhein-Westfalen
und bei Hermann Gröhe für harte
Gespräche wir haben gerungen aber ich
will sagen ich habe Respekt davor dass
Demokraten bei einschneidenden Fragen
die unsere Nation betreffen bei großen
sozialen Fragen in der Lage sind
Kompromisse zu finden die
Unversöhnlichkeit ist nichts was diese
Gesellschaft auszeichnen darf der
Fortschritt will muss zur Kompromissen
in der Lage gehen dafür möchte ich mich
ganz herzlich bedanken
es ist diese große kraftanstrengen wir
zu geführt hat dass die CDU von ihrer
total Blockade abgewichen ist und auch
dafür bedanke
aber bei aller Gemeinsamkeit dass wir
das gemeinsam stemmen ist mir eins
aufgefallen ich habe die Verlautbarung
ihres Fraktionsvorsitzenden letzten
Tagen dazugewiesen wo ist der übrigens
heute gut dass es keine
meldeversäumnisse mit Sanktionen für
Fraktionsvorsitzende gibt uns wissen wir
ja um 10% kürzen
aber unbeschadet spaß beiseite hier ist
eins aufgefallen Herr März hat sehr viel
gesprochen über Begriffe über
Instrumente über die Geschlossenheit der
Union nur eins und das mag der
Unterschied sein hat er nicht getan er
hat niemals über die Menschen gesprochen
um die es geht er hat mich gesprochen
über alleinerziehende Frauen die auf
ergänzende Grundsicherung Bürgergeld
angewiesen sind weil sie nicht Vollzeit
arbeiten können und das machen wir
einfacher wir unterstützen mit dem
höheren Regelsatz gezielt auf vor allen
Dingen alleinerziehende Frauen und
Kinder er hat nicht gesprochen über
diejenigen die als junge Menschen in
Familien groß geworden sind die nie
Arbeit erlebt haben und die sich
aufgerappelt haben eine Ausbildung zu
machen im alten Hartz IV-System erlebt
haben dass die Ausbildungsvergütung noch
gekürzt wurde in der sozialen
Unterstützung das macht das Bürgergeld
besser er hat nie gesprochen über
Facharbeiter die nach Jahren harter
Arbeit unverschuldet ihre Arbeit
verloren haben und auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
keine Chance mehr haben das ändern wir
mit den Steuergeld weil wir den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt in Fristen weil wir
Arbeiten ermöglichen
und er hat nie über selbstständige
gesprochen
die mal vorübergehend weil sie Pech
hatten oder weil es Krisen gab auf
ergänzende Grundsicherung angewiesen
sind mit dem Bürgergeld sorgen wir dafür
dass sie nicht vollständig hier spart es
auf dem Kopf hauen müssen und dass sie
sich nicht sorgen machen müssen auch
noch ihre Wohnung zu verlieren auch
dieser Fortschritt ist dauerhaft mit den
Bürgergeld möglich meine Damen und
Herren
kompromisse sind in der Demokratie
notwendig wenn man sozialen Fortschritt
will und richtig ist es auch dass wir
aufeinander zugehen die Unterschiede
bleiben aber wir koalieren ja nicht
miteinander liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
von der cdu/csu und das ist auch gut so
weil mit dieser Koalition mehr
Fortschritt möglich ist aber eins will
ich Ihnen auch sagen und das ist wichtig
weil es über den Tag hinausgeht nach
vielen Jahren der polarisierten Debatte
und das System der Grundsicherung hat
vier und gerade nach den letzten Wochen
bietet dieser Weg den wir gemeinsam
gefunden haben die Chance eine
gesellschaftliche Polarisierung zu
entgiften ich meine das ganz ernst meine
Damen und Herren wir haben ja seit
Jahren erlebt das ist extreme Positionen
gegeben hat was die Frage von Menschen
in der Grundsicherung hat es hier
gegeben hat da gab es die
wieso getan haben als da die Mehrheit
oder sogar alle Menschen die bedürftig
sind zu faul zu arbeiten da gab es die
anderen die haben so getan als sei jede
Mitwirkungspflicht schon einen Anschlag
auf die Menschenwürde beide extremen
Positionen sind unvernünftig und durch
das Bürgergeld haben wir eine Chance mit
breiter Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
und im Bundesrat dafür zu sorgen dass
wir eine vernünftiges System nach vorne
entwickelt bekommen aber dass wir durch
eine Entgiftung der Debatte auch einen
Beitrag zum gesellschaftlichen
Zusammenhalt als meine Damen und das
brauchen unsere Gesellschaft in Zeiten
von Krisen in Zeiten des Wandels
und deshalb will ich abschließend sagen
meine Damen und Herren Chancen und
Schutz das ist das Motto dieser
Bundesregierung und das werden wir
weiterhin der arbeitsmarkt-sozialpolitik
als unser Leitmotiv machen aber
wichtiger als mottiger als auch
Leitmotive ist der Blick auf die
Lebenswirklichkeit von Menschen und die
verbessern wir mit unserer Arbeitsmarkt
und Sozialpolitik Schritt für Schritt
und jetzt machen wir einen großen
Schritt mit dem Bürgergeld und morgen
haben sie alle die Chance zuzustimmen
herzlichen Dank
Hubertus Heil hat es angesprochen morgen
wird der Bundestag hier ohne Aussprache
dem Kompromiss Ergebnis des
Vermittlungsausschusses zustimmen und
dann ist diese Abstimmung auch im
Bundesrat Morgen und dann wird diese
Reform zum ersten ersten greifen dann
heißt es nicht mehr Hartz IV sondern
Bürger Geld und das ist ein wichtiges
Ziel gewesen von Hubertus Heil Rene
Springer jetzt für die AFD
ich möchte mit einem Zitat beginnen von
Ludwig Erhard der mal sagte die
Inflation kommt nicht über uns als ein
Fluch oder als ein tragisches Geschick
sie wird immer durch eine leichtfertige
oder sogar verbrecherische Politik
hervorgerufen ich finde nichts passt
besser in die heutige Zeit als dieser
Satz vom Vater der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft
die Inflation hat aktuell den höchsten
Wert seit fast 50 Jahren erreicht jeder
siebte muss sich höher verschulden jeder
zweite sorgt sich inzwischen um sein
Lebensunterhalt die Lebensmittel Tafeln
verhängen Aufnahmestopps weil sie den
Ansturm nicht mehr bewältigen können
Millionen wissen nicht wie Sie die
nächste Energierechnung bezahlen sollen
und Minister heil und die gesamte
Bundesregierung eben auch die
kartellparteien hier im Parlament sehen
die Schuld dafür bei Putin aber das ist
eben nichts mehr als eine dreiste Lüge
die Inflation lag im dezember 2021 bei
5,3% zu dem Zeitpunkt der höchste Wert
seit 30 Jahren Gemüse kostete 10% mehr
Kraftstoffe 33% Heizöl 60%. zu dem
Zeitpunkt hatte noch kein einziger
russischer Soldat ukrainischen Boden
betreten und das zeigt eben dass das
alles was sie erzählen eine große Lüge
ist
die Verantwortung für die Inflation
liegt nicht bei Putin sondern bei den
kartellparteien sie allein tragen die
Verantwortung dafür dass die
Energiepolitik gescheitert ist dass die
Steuern unerträglich hoch sind in
Deutschland dass unser
landwirtschaftlich stark beschädigt
wurde durch die corona-maßnahmen seit
einem Jahrzehnt dulden sie die
verbrecherische Gelddruckerei der EZB
und sie alle Stützen den
Wirtschaftskrieg gegen Russland
Aufgabe aber einer Regierung ist es
nicht unsere Bürger in Armut zu stürzen
und Deutschland wirtschaftlich zu
ruinieren sondern für bezahlbare Energie
zu sorgen und die Ursachen der Inflation
zu bekämpfen und das geht eben nicht mit
billigen Bahntickets und mickrigen
Einmalzahlungen die obendrein auch noch
versteuert werden müssen das geht nur
das geht nur mit einer entschlossenen
Politik nach dem Prinzip Deutschland und
die deutschen Bürger immer zuerst
schluss mit den Sanktionen gegen
Russland Schluss mit der Gelddruckerei
Schluss mit der Abzocke der Steuerzahler
was wir brauchen sind Steuerentlastungen
billiges Gas aus nordstream 2 und ein
sofortigen Wiedereinstieg in die
Kernenergie aber all das
all das verweigern sie stattdessen
treten sie den Bürgern unseres Landes
beim Fallen noch in den Rücken indem sie
aus dem deutschen Sozialstaat ein Mekka
für Migranten machen inzwischen haben 45
Prozent aller Hartz IV Empfänger in
Deutschland keinen deutschen Pass in
Bayern sind es sogar 55 Prozent ich
frage mich warum Hartz IV Bürgergeld
heißen soll wenn die Hälfte der Bezieher
überhaupt keine Bürger unseres Landes
sind
sie sollten das ganze zuwanderungsprämie
nennen dann werden sie näher an der
Wahrheit ab Januar gibt es vom ersten
Tag an 500 Euro auf die Hand dazu Miete
Heizkosten Betriebskosten
Krankenversicherung Geld für Möbel Geld
für Klassenfahrten Befreiung von den
Kita-Gebühren und Befreiung vom
gez-zwangsbeitrag was für ein
Nackenschlag für mindestlohnempfänger
die mit einem 40 Stunden Job kaum mehr
in der Tasche haben am Monatsende als
ein Hartz IV Empfänger
was was für eine Respektlosigkeit
gegenüber 5 Millionen Rentnern in
Deutschland die weniger als 1000 Euro
monatlich zur Verfügung haben und was
für einen hohen gegenüber Jobcenter
Mitarbeitern die ihrem Gegenüber Miete
und Heizkosten bewilligen müssen die
oftmals über dem liegen was sich die
Jobcenter Mitarbeiter selber noch
leisten können das alles ist einfach nur
noch absurd was sie sich erlauben die
Bild-Zeitung schreibt gestern im
Jobcenter sitzen die Mitarbeiter bei 19
Grad während sich ausländische Hartz IV
lawundern warum es dort so viel kälter
ist als in ihren Wohnungen bei denen
werden die Heizkosten übrigens auch noch
vom Amt übernommen das ist eine irre
Politik die nichts anderes ist als
inländerfeindlich
im kommenden Jahr wird die
Bundesregierung weit mehr als 15
Milliarden Euro für ausländische
bürgergeld-empfänger ausgeben für die
Grundrente finden wir im Haushalt gerade
mal eine Milliarde Euro das sagt einfach
alles über die falschen Prioritäten
dieser Bundesregierung
sie reden ständig von Respekt aber sie
sollen Migranten die nie einen Cent in
Sozialsystem eingezahlt haben mehr
Respekt als den deutschen Rentnern und
den deutschen Steuerzahlern der Vater
der Vater der sozialen Marktwirtschaft
würde heute vermutlich sagen die
Einwanderung in die Sozialsysteme kommt
nicht über uns als ein Fluch oder als
ein tragisches Geschick
sie wird immer durch eine leichtfertige
oder sogar verbrecherische Politik
hervorgerufen und ich hoffe dass diese
Bundesregierung und die kartellparteien
hier im Parlament eines Tages dafür zur
Verantwortung gezogen werden danke für
die Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der Bundestag debattiert in der
haushaltswoche jetzt über den Einzelplan
elf seit heute morgen um 9 Uhr Arbeit
und Soziales und der nächste Redner hier
ist Andreas audritsch für die
Bündnisgrünen erst stellvertretender
Fraktionsvorsitzender
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren die wichtigste Nachricht zu
allererstes Bürgergeld kommt es kommt
zum ersten Januar 2023 das bedeutet 50
Euro mehr für die Menschen im Bürgergeld
aber eins ist auch klar dass Bürgergeld
ist viel mehr als nur diese
Regelsatzerhöhung
ich habe mir die Pressekonferenz von
Herrn März angeschaut und das was mich
am meisten erstaunt hat bei dieser
Pressekonferenz war dass er märz nicht
einen einzigen Satz über das Bürgergeld
gesagt hat er hat nicht einen Satz in
der Sache gesagt und er hat und das ist
ein fast noch schlimmer nicht einen Satz
über die Menschen gesagt um diese
eigentlich geht und das sagt etwas über
die Union in den letzten Wochen ging es
vielen von ihnen vor allem den
redelsführern nicht um die Menschen es
ging um Stimmungsmache und das ist das
Problem ihrer Politik in den letzten
Wochen gewesen
ich sage Ihnen was über die Menschen
wenn eine Familie ein Schicksalsschlag
erleidet und Leistungen beantragen muss
dann ist es unter Hartz IV häufig so
gewesen dass das allererste was diese
Menschen tun müssen eine neue Wohnung zu
suchen ist weil die Wohnung ein kleines
bisschen zu groß war und was bedeutet
das für die Menschen das bedeutet Kinder
aus der Kita nehmen das bedeutet die
Freunde im Umfeld zurücklassen das
bedeutet all das nur eben nicht sich auf
die Jobsuche zur konzentrieren und genau
das ändern wir jetzt mit dem Bürgergeld
die Karenzzeit von 12 Monaten gibt
Menschen genau diese Chance sich zu
konzentrieren auf die Jobsuche
und
wer einmal im Jobcenter war der weiß
auch die ganzen Geschichten darüber dass
Menschen immer wieder in den nächst
schlechtesten im prekäre Jobs geschickt
wurde diesen drehtüreffekt das ist Hartz
IV und genau das schaffen wir jetzt ab
und deswegen
und deswegen schaffen wir einen
Paradigmen
Paradigmenwechsel indem wir sagen in den
Jobcentern wird ab sofort nicht mehr in
den nächst schlechtesten Job vermittelt
sondern es geht um Qualifizierung es
geht um Weiterbildung endlich
finanzieren wir eine dreijährige
Berufsausbildung und oben drauf oben
drauf gibt es 150 €, wenn man sich genau
dafür entscheidet nämlich Fachkraft zu
werden das ist der Kern wir setzen auf
positive Anreize wir setzen darauf dass
Menschen voran kommen wollen und
deswegen ist es ein fundamentaler
Unterschied zu dem was ihn hat hier noch
gegolten hat und wir setzen auch auf
positive Anreize für Jugendliche was für
eine schreckliche Situation für Kinder
was Hartz 4 Familien wenn alle in der
Schule ein Nebenjob machen um am
Wochenende sich was leisten zu können
nur die Hartz IV Kinder müssen alles
abgeben am Ende ein Großteil abgeben
auch das beenden wir wir werden dieses
System beenden weil wir nicht zulassen
und nicht hinnehmen dass Kinder für die
finanzielle Situation ihrer Eltern
bestraft werden das beenden wir und
diesen Geist das den Geist des Zutrauens
und den Geist der Anreize der spiegelt
sich auch bei den Regelungen zu den
Sanktionen wieder wir senken die
Sanktionen massiv mit diesem Gesetz das
Bundesverfassungsgericht lässt 30
Prozent Sanktionen zu wir starten mit
zehn Prozent weil wir nicht darauf
setzen auf maximale Strafe hinaus zu
sein sondern weil wir darauf aus sind
gemeinsam Perspektive und Zukunft zu
entwickeln
die Verbesserungen des Bürgergeldes
werden zum ersten Januar kommen
und das trotz einer Kampagne die in den
letzten Wochen mit brutaler Kälte gegen
Menschen in der Grundsicherung geführt
wurde mich hat diese Kälte gerade von
Seiten der Union in den letzten Monaten
in den letzten Wochen schockiert das
muss ich Ihnen sagen wenn es nur noch
darum geht die Gesellschaft gegen arme
Menschen aufzuwickeln hat das nichts mit
einem christlichen Menschenbild zu tun
das was wir machen ist weiter zu kämpfen
für arme Menschen das ist was wir machen
ist zusammenzuarbeiten mit den Kirchen
mit den Gewerkschaften mit den
Wohlfahrtsverbänden und mit den Menschen
die selber in Armut leben müssen wir
kämpfen weiter für eine andere
gerechtere Gesellschaft mit den Menschen
zusammen das ist unsere grüne Agenda und
die werden wir auch in Zukunft
fortsetzen herzlichen Dank
Andreas auditsch nutze seine Redezeit um
sich hier an der Union abzuarbeiten
gestern gab es einen Kompromiss im
Vermittlungsausschuss ohne die Union und
diesen Kompromiss würde das Bürgergeld
nicht am ersten Januar in Kraft treten
können Matthias Birg weil jetzt für die
Linke Sprecher für Renten und
alterssicherungs-
lieber Bundesminister Hubertus Heil 1991
wurden bestimmte Rentenansprüche aus
DDR-Zeiten nicht in das bundesdeutsche
Rentensystem übernommen zu Unrecht
wir linken fordern seit 30 Jahren das
beispielsweise ehemalige Eisenbahner
Postler Ballettänzerinnen und in der DDR
geschiedene Frauen Gerechtigkeit zu Teil
werden muss und ihre Ansprüche für die
sie Beiträge gezahlt haben
berücksichtigt werden mögen
gut dass sie mit dem härtefallfonds
endlich das Renten Unrecht Ost
anerkennen mehr Lob gibt es leider nicht
denn einmalig und insgesamt nur extrem
bescheidene 500 Millionen Euro für
ostdeutsche deren Rentenansprüche nicht
anerkannt wurden für Spätaussiedler und
die jüdischen Kontingentflüchtlinge aus
der Sowjetunion sind nur ein sehr
schlechter Witz
eine Einmalzahlung von gerade einmal
2500 Euro wird keiner dieser betroffenen
Gruppen auch nur im ansatzgerecht auf
eine durchschnittliche Rentenbezugsdauer
sind das umgerechnet nur zehn Euro 42 im
Monat Martin Rosemann und da sollten Sie
sich schämen denn das ist beschämen und
für 100000 Menschen respektlos und
demütigen ich fordere die
Bundesregierung darum auf gewähren sie
erstens die Einmalzahlung nicht nur den
Bedürftigen denn hier geht es um Respekt
vor der Lebensleistung von ostdeutschen
und aus der Sowjetunion zugewanderte
Juden und aussieht dann und machen Sie
zweitens aus dem härtefallfonds einen
gerechtigkeitsform und da hören sie die
Einmalzahlung auf mindestens 10.000 Euro
die Finanzierung dafür kann ich Ihnen
gerne nennen
verzichten Sie auf die 10 Milliarden
Euro zockergeld der FDP für die
sogenannte aktienrente
meine Damen und Herren sie wollen
ernsthaft die 10 Milliarden Euro für
ihre überflüssige aktienrente auf
punktfinanzieren und das bei massiv
steigenden Anleihezinsen und
gleichzeitig sinkenden Aktienkursen die
aktienrente kommt nur dann ins Plus wenn
die Renditen die Kreditzinsen
übersteigender doch jede
sparkassenberaterin den Kopf zocken ist
kein Konzept für stabile und sichere
Renten Finanzen darum lassen sie das
sorgen Sie für ein dauerhaft höheres
Rentenniveau mehr tarifliche Entlohnung
Sozialversicherungspflicht ab der ersten
Arbeitsstunde und für echte Arbeitgeber
finanzierte Betriebsrenten sorgen Sie
dafür dass wir freiwillige zusätzliche
Einzahlung möglich machen die IG Metall
nennt das so die Rente ich bin für mehr
Solingen Rente statt aktienrente
herzlichen Dank
so und der nächste Sinnes Pascal Kober
von der FDP jetzt Sprecher für
Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik der
Liberalen
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen für die Arbeitsmarkt und
Sozialpolitik werden im kommenden Jahr
163,3 Milliarden Euro zur Verfügung
stellen das ist die größte Summe die der
Bundeshaushalt für einen einzelnen
politischen Arbeitsbereich zur Verfügung
stellt und diese
163,3 Milliarden Euro die die
Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahler für
die Arbeitsmarkt und Sozialpolitik zur
Verfügung stellen ist bei ihnen mit
einer Hoffnung verbunden natürlich auf
der einen Seite dass wir den Menschen
die im Laufe ihres Lebens Straucheln
unter die Arme greifen aber vor allen
Dingen auch dass wir Sie unterstützen
und ihn wieder aufhelfen um
Selbstständigkeit und freies Leben als
Bürger wieder zu unterstützen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und das machen wir genau mit diesem
bürgergeldgesetz das jetzt im kommenden
Jahr Gesetz werden wird das geht genau
in diese Richtung es geht nicht nur um
die Erhöhung von Regelsätzen die richtig
ist weil es dabei um den
Inflationsausgleich geht sondern es geht
vor allen Dingen um mehr Vorankommen um
mehr Chancen und um mehr Motivation es
geht um ein positives Menschenbild und
ich bin da sehr sehr froh dass dieses
Bürgergeld diesen neuen Geist in sich
aufnimmt und dass wir in Zukunft die
Menschen wieder viel viel stärker von
ihren Potenzialen her begreifen werden
von dem was sie können was in ihnen
steckt statt von dem sie von der Seite
anzusprechen was Sie vielleicht nicht
können oder was sie im Moment noch nicht
sind liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und wir wollen auch Motivation im
Sozialstaat und deshalb werden wir die
Zuverdienstgrenzen in einem ersten
Schritt schon mal nach oben führen das
ist Leistungsgerechtigkeit weil ob
jemand sich schwer tut im Arbeitsmarkt
oder es leichter hat wer viel verdient
oder wenig verdient
Leistungsgerechtigkeit seine Form der
Gerechtigkeit die jedem in diesem Land
zusteht und hier gehen wir einen Schritt
nach vorne
und Leistungsgerechtigkeit ist auch eine
Investition in die Zukunft
wir wollen damit Schluss machen dass
junge Menschen mit unter die aller Zeit
Arbeitslosigkeit ihrer Eltern Erben
müssen wir werden den Menschen jungen
Menschen besser fördern als bisher und
auch dadurch dass wir ihnen gerecht
werden denn ein junger Mensch der
beispielsweise eine Ausbildungsvergütung
von 800 Euro bekommen hat bisher in der
von der CDU unterstützen Systematik nur
240 Euro davon behalten dürfen er darf
künftig 6004 Euro erhalten ich verstehe
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Union warum sie dazu in der
Vergangenheit nie bereit waren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
da haben sie hart zugegriffen und das
hat auch damit dazu geführt dass viele
gar nicht die Motivation hatten eine
Ausbildung zu beginnen damit machen wir
jetzt Schluss unsere Sozialstaat muss
aufstiegsorientierter werden er wird es
mit den Bürgergeld er muss motivierender
werden er wird es mit dem Bürgergeld er
wird chancenreicher werden er wird es
mit diesen Bürgergeld vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
Pascal kuba hat es angesprochen also das
Bürgergeld morgen wird es verabschiedet
im Bundestag und im Bundesrat ist
eingestellt im Bereich Arbeit und
Soziales mit
23,76 Milliarden Euro das sind ungefähr
2,5 Milliarden mehr als in diesem Jahr
und Peter auch mal jetzt der nächste
Schritt für die Union über Prinzipien zu
diskutieren überprinzipien die unser
Land in den letzten 70 Jahren getragen
haben der Sozialstaat und die soziale
Marktwirtschaft sie in der Ampel
Koalition meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren sehen leider das und dazwischen
relativ stark und vergessen dass wir
Sozialstaat und soziale Marktwirtschaft
gemeinsam sehen müssen und ich teile
Ihre Einschätzung das Schutz und Chance
in einer gemeinsamen Verbindung gesehen
werden Herr Minister aber leider haben
sie und die Redner ihre Ampelkoalition
heute auch Prinzipien hin anstehen
lassen wenn man die reden lieber von
Ihnen Herr Kurt von ihnen anhört dann
glaube ich merkt man sehr deutlich dass
es diese Richtung die Sache geht sondern
dass sie gemerkt haben dass die Mehrheit
der Menschen in diesem Land nicht denken
wie Sie dass wir nicht vergessen haben
die Lebensleistung der Menschen zu
schätzen sondern dass sie in ihrem
Regierungshandeln die Mehrheit der
Menschen nicht hinter sich haben und das
ist in ihren Reden sehr deutlich
geworden
beim Bürgergeld und das nochmal
aufzugreifen meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren ist es der Ampel vor allem
darum gegangen ein Trauma zu bewältigen
hat vier muss weg den Einstieg in ein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen zu
schaffen und bei der FDP war
Totalausfall die Anrechnungen die sind
denke ich relativ gut aber beim Rest
haben sie einfach mitgemacht ohne zu
schauen welche Auswirkungen das für die
Wirtschaft in unserem Land hat meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
gerade in der Zeit in der wir leben
müssen wir stärker auf die Verbindung
von Sozialstaat und soziale
Marktwirtschaft schauen wir müssen die
Drohne Rezession die steigende Inflation
den Arbeits- und Fachkräftemangel in den
Blick nehmen aber auch die Situation der
Sozialsysteme in unserem Land ich möchte
drei Beispiele aus dem Haushalt nennen
einmal Herr Heil sie haben vorher so
getan als wäre das Bürgergeld die Lösung
für alles ich glaube es wird sehr
deutlich dass es das nicht ist wenn man
dann in den Haushalt geschaut Herr kurz
wir haben gesagt sie würden gerne über
viele Themen reden genau diese Themen
über diese reden wollten die für ich an
sie kürzen im Haushalt den
Eingliederungstitel in Arbeit
beträchtlich und sagen dann nach uns
geht es bei Bürgergeld ja darum dass man
den Menschen stärker in Arbeit kommt
bekommt dass man sie ausbildet wir haben
als große Koalition den Menschen die
Möglichkeit gegeben mit dem sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt langfristig auch Menschen
die Förderung brauchen zu integrieren
sie kürzen diesen Titel und das denke
ich ist fast schon schädlich wenn man
die Debatte vorher hört
wenn man
Kollege einmal weiterschauen nein danke
wir können dann später diskutieren jetzt
bringt es glaube ich relativ wenig sie
haben die Zeit gehabt in ihrer Rede
haben das nicht getan haben nur auf uns
geschimpft und dann müssen sie das auch
anhören die
Haushaltstitel berufliche Integration
und Beratung von Zuwanderern und die
berufsbezogene Deutsch Sprachförderung
wird gekürzt meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren der Ampel bei 600.000
ukrainischen Flüchtlingen die in das
grundsicherungssystem kommen ist auch
das unverantwortungslos und ich glaube
sie widersprechen ihrer Politik da
deutlich und ein letztes Beispiel es ist
vorher schon angesprochen worden die
aktienrente hochgelobter von der FDP in
diesem Haushalt wieder nichts zu finden
es ist ja mittlerweile angekündigt dass
es über Kredite finanzieren wollen wenn
man dann liest dass die Rente Enkel fit
sein soll dann glaube ich zeigt es auch
ein klein bisschen den Widerspruch ihrer
Arbeit und wenn man dann die F die
Pressemeldung zur aktienrente liest dass
das vielleicht die größte Rentenreform
seit Bismarck sein soll meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren hätte Bismarck
gearbeitet wie sieht es tun dann wäre
der Sozialstaat nicht auf starken Säulen
wir das heute ist
oder nicht zuletzt wenn die Rednerin der
FDP liebe Frau Raphael
Anstand zu tun sondern mit Wahrheit
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren und
nicht zuletzt wenn sie dann noch die
Kürzungen beim
transformationsprojekt Arbeitswelt im
Wandel jetzt große herausstellen dass
sie da über 10 Millionen Euro gestrichen
haben dann glaube ich ist es in einer
Zeit wo unsere Wirtschaft bei einer
großen Transformation steht auch etwas
was für die FDP spricht was zeigt dass
ihnen Zukunftsprojekte weniger wichtig
sind als der Titel in ihrer Koalition
fortschrittskoalition zu sein meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren reicht nicht
aus wenn man unserem Land keine Zukunft
gibt meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren für uns steht fordern und fördern
als ganz wesentlicher Punkt und ich habe
mir die letzten Wochen sehr intensiv
gedacht warum man da so streiten kann
weil eigentlich ist dieser Begriff ja
Inbegriff dessen was Deutschland in die
letzten in den letzten Jahrzehnten stark
gemacht hat fordern und fördern bedeutet
die Verbindung von so hat und sozialer
Marktwirtschaft wir als Union haben in
den letzten Jahren ganz ganz intensiv
Wert darauf gelegt und auch in den
letzten Wochen und haben unseren Beitrag
dazu geleistet dass dieser Maßstab immer
im Fokus geblieben ist herzlichen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
bevor ich den nächsten Redner Aufrufe
hat das Wort zu einer Kurzintervention
der Kollege Markus Kurt aus der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen
ich darf Ihnen auch als Berichterstatter
für die Grünen für den Einzelplan 11 für
diesen Haushalt doch noch ein paar
Fakten mitgeben die sie glaube ich nicht
so richtig mitbekommen haben und auch
der Herr Stracke nicht eben in seiner
Rede was den Eingliederungstitel
anbelangt und den verwaltungskostentitel
ist es richtig dass es eine Kürzung um
650 Millionen Euro gegeben hat im
Entwurf für 2023 gegenüber 2022 wenn Sie
genau nachsehen dann stellen sie fest
dass der verwaltungstitel um 200
Millionen erhöht worden ist der
Eingliederungstitel wiederum und 200
Millionen und das drittens 100 Millionen
dann im Einzelplan 60 ebenfalls mit
Bezug auf die eingliederungsmittel
eingestellt worden sind macht zusammen
500 Millionen bleibt ein Delta von 150
Millionen das aber wenn wir sehen dass
in den vergangenen Jahren immer
ausgabereste da waren geschlossen werden
kann durch einen vernünftigen
Mittelabfluss und durch eine vernünftige
mittelbewirtschaftung unterjährig worauf
wir alle als ampelhaushälter achten
werden dann haben sie
dann haben sie den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt
den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt angesprochen
und beklagt es sei da zu wenig ich darf
daran erinnern dass es die Union war die
in der vergangenen Legislaturperiode bei
der Einführung des
teilhabengesetzes dieses befristet hat
und was wir morgen machen werden ist
dass wir das entfristen
und und zu guter Letzt zu guter Letzt
haben Sie hier einen im Vergleich zu dem
groß erscheinenden gesamteta 10
Millionen genannt die wir bei dem bei
der Titelgruppe Arbeitswelt im Wandel
gekürzt haben und da darf ich Ihnen das
einfach nur erklären dass wir als
verantwortungsvolle Haushälter Frau
Raffelhüschen hat es auch genannt
natürlich darauf achten ist ein
ausreichender Mittelabfluss da und da wo
Mittel Bewirtschaftung Spielräume lässt
da werden wir natürlich auch vernünftig
und mit Augenmaß das ganze koeffizienz
Gesichtspunkten durchforsten danke schön
dass Sie das zugelassen haben über die
Zeit Frau Präsident entschuldigung das
heißt Kurzintervention
sie dürfen Stellung nehmen
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin Herr Kurt
sie hätten eigentlich in ihrer Rede
Möglichkeit gehabt all diese Dinge zu
besprechen sie haben fünf Minuten oder
sechs Minuten genutzt um auf die CDT zu
schimpfen das
zeigt auch wie wenig Argumente sie haben
vielleicht ganz kurz zu den Punkten wir
hatten ein sehr intensives Gespräch mit
Andrea Nahles
und sie hat gesagt dass alleine der
Titel wenn er nicht gekürzt worden wäre
mit den ukrainischen Flüchtlingen nicht
ausgereicht hätte also sie hätten nicht
nur die Kürzung rückgängig machen müssen
sondern sie hätten sogar aufstocken
müssen und wenn Sie jetzt mit der
Verwaltungskosten kommen dann sollten
Sie doch bitte auch mal schauen dass
auch bei der Bundesagentur für Arbeit
Inflation ein wichtiger Punkt ist also
auch die 200 Millionen die reichen da
auch nicht aus deswegen deswegen Herr
Kurt bleiben sie da bei der Wahrheit und
schauen Sie dass Sie dieses wesentlich
wichtige Feld für die Integration von
ausländischen Menschen von Zuwanderern
auch dementsprechend verantwortungsvoll
finanziell ausstatten und zum Thema
Arbeitswelt im Wandel das sollte der
kompletten Regierung zu denken geben
wenn man die Mittel die da sind für die
Transformation der Wirtschaft nicht
ausschöpft und sieht es dann begründen
weil nicht aus Geschäft müssen wir
kürzen ist denke ich auch ein
Widerspruch in sich dann soll das
Bundesarbeitsministerium dann soll das
Bundesarbeitsministerium da stärker
arbeiten und Impulse geben das glaube
ich wäre viel wichtiger
nächster Redner für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Martin Rosemann
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren in der letzten
Sitzungswoche bei der Debatte über das
Bürgergeld habe ich Ihnen gesagt wir
werden die Jobcenter mit den notwendigen
Mitteln ausstatten und jetzt beschließen
wir eine Erhöhung der Mittel für die
Jobcenter von 500 Millionen Euro während
die Union des Thema Jobcenter und
eingliederungsmittel immer nur dann
entdeckt wenn sie in der Opposition ist
hält die Ampel Wort
meine Damen und Herren
das Bürgergeld kann kommen des
Bürgergeld kommt Hartz IV ist Geschichte
und ich muss Ihnen schon sagen Herr
Gröhe sie haben vor zwei Wochen noch im
Interviews gesagt das Gesetz wird
scheitern jetzt stimmen sie morgen zu
schön dass sie dazu gelernt haben
und natürlich natürlich
müssen wir Kompromisse machen das gilt
vor allem für das Thema
Karenzzeit und Schonvermögen aber es
bleibt bei dem was die Ampel hier
vorgelegt hat nämlich bei mehr Respekt
für Lebensleistungen auch wenn sie von
der Union das nicht wollten es macht
einen Unterschied ob jemand immer
gearbeitet hat und was und sich was
erspart hat oder nicht
meine Damen und Herren auch alle anderen
Kernpunkte des Bürgergelds die ich in
der vergangenen Sitzungswoche hier von
diesem Pult angesprochen habe bleiben
ebenfalls bestehen es bleibt bei mehr
Augenhöhe und damit bei einem neuen
Umgang zwischenstaat und Bürgern der
kooperationsplan wird auf Augenhöhe
gemeinsam vereinbart und wenn das nicht
klappt dann kann die Schlichtungsstelle
angerufen werden es bleibt
bei mir Zielgenauigkeit beim fordern und
da müssen wir vielleicht mal jetzt ein
bisschen aufklären Herr Stracke
also Mitwirkungspflichten von Beginn an
nach Antragstellung ab dem ersten Tag
die waren schon im bisherigen Entwurf
drin und dabei bleibt es auch und dabei
bleibt es auch nein wer wer nein wir
lesen kann ist klar im Vorteil dabei
bleibt es auch und es bleibt auch
und es bleibt auch dabei dass wer von
Beginn an mitwirkt nicht sofort mit
Sanktionen bedroht wird und es bleibt
auch dabei dass wir aus gesundheitlichen
Gründen nicht mitwirken kann dass der
entsprechend unterstützt wird dabei
bleibt es und das noch richtig so
und es bleibt es bleibt bei mir fördern
mit dem umfassenden Coaching der
Entfristung des sozialen Arbeitsmarkts
der aufsuchenden Arbeit in
Weiterbildungsgeld und den Bürger
geldbuß sorgen wir für bessere
individuelle und passgenaue
Unterstützung und es bleibt bei mir
Nachhaltigkeit wir schaffen den
vermittlungsvorgang ab
passgenaue nachhaltige Vermittlungen
statt schnelle Vermittlung in irgendeine
Arbeit ist die Devise
also
schließlich bleibt es bei mir
Leistungsgerechtigkeit beim Zuverdienst
haben junge Leute in Zukunft mehr damit
sie die Erfahrung machen können dass ich
Arbeit auch lohnt die Ampel meine Damen
und Herren sorgt für sozialen
Zusammenhalt in der Krise und für
soziale Sicherheit in Zeiten des
Umbruchs you will never walk alone das
gilt in der Energiekrise genauso wie im
Strukturwandel alle sollen gut durch
diesen Winter kommen die Unternehmen
ihre Beschäftigten und deren Familien
auch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger die auf
Grundsicherung angewiesen sind dafür
führen wir eine gaspreisbremse eine
fernwärme-bremse eine strompreisbremse
ein und dafür erhöhen wir den Regelsatz
meine Damen und Herren
vor allem
vor allem entlasten wir diejenigen die
sich anstrengen die arbeiten und
trotzdem keinen dicken Geldbeutel haben
das Gebiete der Respekt vor deren
Leistung wir senken die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge für niedrig
wird Ihnen wie erhöhen das Kindergeld
für alle Kinder auf 250 Euro wir erhöhen
den Kinderzuschlag wir machen die größte
wohngeldreform Erhöhen des Wohngeld und
weitens aus und wir haben den
Mindestlohn auf 12 Euro erhöht und
sorgen damit dafür dass Arbeit und
Leistung den Unterschied machen
und
wer will
wer will dass ich leistung lohnt der
hätte für 12 Euro Mindestlohn Stimmen
sollen das haben sie nicht gemacht
meine Damen und Herren die Ampel sorgt
für soziale Sicherheit und sozialen
Fortschritt in Zeiten der Veränderungen
deshalb werden wir auch dafür sorgen
dass das Rentenniveau über 2025 hinaus
stabil bleibt wir sorgen dafür dass alle
durch die Energie und die
mobilitätswende gute Perspektiven haben
und deshalb werden wir die Beschäftigten
im Strukturwandel noch wirkungsvoller
bei der Weiterbildung unterstützen wir
werden ein Weiterbildungspaket vorlegen
damit die Beschäftigten von heute die
Arbeit von morgen machen können
und
wir werden alles dafür tun
dass die notwendigen Fachkräfte in
diesem Strukturwandel verfügbar sind
damit die Energiewende gelingt und damit
die sozialen Dienstleistungen die diese
Gesellschaft zu dringend braucht denken
Sie an Pflege und an Kinderbetreuung
dass die auch wirklich erbracht werden
können deshalb wird diese Ampelkoalition
ein Einwanderungsgesetz vorlegen was
diesen Namen auch verdient Einwanderung
ist notwendig aber reicht nicht aus
genauso wichtig sind inländische
Potenziale unter Frauen durch bessere
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf und
der Langzeitarbeitslosen deshalb ist es
Bürgergeld mit seiner Priorität auf
individuelle Förderung zielgenau
Weiterbildung und nachhaltige
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
wichtig und unter älteren deshalb
schaffen wir die Hinzuverdienstgrenzen
ab für Leute die vorzeitig in die Rente
gehen und machen ein Programm für
gesunde Arbeit Stärken Prävention und
Reha damit beschäftigte länger gesund im
Arbeitsleben bleiben können insgesamt
meine Damen und Herren sorgt die Ampel
für sozialen Zusammenhalt Respekt vor
der Lebensleistung und sozialen
Fortschritt dafür steht dieser Haushalt
Martin Rosemann war das für die SPD der
Bundestag debattiert über den Einzelplan
11 Arbeit und Soziales und der Sprecher
für Arbeit und Soziales der Bündnis
können in frank sierke hat als nächster
das Wort Präsident Abgeordnete
zudem mit Ignoranz und Lügen durch
tränken schäbigkeitswettbewerb
in den vergangenen Wochen die Herren
märz und Söder gestürzt haben mit der
AFD
hat der Arbeitsminister alles
Erforderliche gesagt ich will mich
deshalb auf den Haushalt konzentrieren
der enthält gegenüber der ursprünglichen
Vorlage wichtige Veränderungen den
Jobcentern werden 200 Millionen Euro
zusätzlich an Verwaltungskosten zur
Verfügung gestellt und der
Eingliederungstitel wird de facto um 300
Millionen Euro aufgestockt ich begrüße
das ausdrücklich
es ist mit Blick auf die
bürgergeldreform zwingend notwendig wir
wollen nämlich mit dem Bürgergeld eine
neue Sozialpolitik einleiten die Agenda
2010 entgiften und eine neue Kultur des
Förderns an die Stelle von Hartz 4
setzen
Mitwirkungspflichten das auch weiterhin
geben ebenso wie die Möglichkeit zu
Leistungsminderung aber der Geist der
Geist des neuen Systems soll nicht der
von Misstrauen sein sondern von
Ermutigung und Befähigung von Hilfe zur
gesellschaftlichen Teilnahme
das fördernde verstärkt ohne das fordern
aufzugeben
entscheidend wird sein dass im
Einvernehmen auf Augenhöhe im
kooperationsplan ein in die Zukunft
gerichteter Weg vereinbart wird der den
Menschen eine Perspektive auf dem
Arbeitsmarkt erschließt keine Frage die
Einführung des Bürgergeldes stellt die
Jobcenter vor große Herausforderungen
die neuen Aufgaben werden mit dem
bisherigen personalkörpern nicht
durchführbar sein deshalb ist es
folgerichtig jetzt auch die
Verwaltungskosten anzupassen und
zusätzliche personelle und finanzielle
Ressourcen einzuplanen wir tragen dem
unabhängig von ihrem Geschrei mit
verbesserten Haushaltsansätzen ebenso
Rechnung wie mit der Bereitstellung von
2,4 Milliarden Euro für das Bürgergeld
darüber hinaus
heben wir die Mittel für die Kosten der
Unterkunft um 400 Millionen Euro an und
stocken auch den Haushaltsansatz für die
berufliche Integration und Beratung von
zuwandernden um 26 Millionen Euro für
die Jahre 24 und 25 in Form von
Verpflichtungsermächtigungen auf das ist
Ausdruck des manifesten Interesses an
der Gewinnung ausländischer Fachkräfte
für einen naked in Germany
und verändert geblieben
gegenüber dem Haushaltsentwurf ist
hingegen der Ansatz für berufsbezogene
Sprachförderung mit einer Kürzung von
140 Millionen Euro gegenüber Vorjahren
und das obwohl die Zahl der an
sprachförderkursen teilnehmende nicht
zuletzt in Folge der hohen Zahl aus der
Ukraine absehbar ansteigen dürfte und
auch die Honorare der Lehrkräfte
angehoben werden müssen
andernfalls würde es immer schwieriger
qualifizierte Fachkräfte zu gewinnen
Sprachförderung ist für eine gelingende
Integration ausländischer Arbeitskräfte
von zentraler Bedeutung hierzu so steht
es in den Eckpunkten zur Fachkräfte
Einwanderung wollen wir Zitat im Inland
die im Ausland die für das
Gesamtprogramm nötigen Haushaltsmittel
erhöhen
vor diesem Hintergrund überrascht es
dass das Bundesarbeitsministerium den
Haushaltsansatz für berufsbezogene
Sprachförderung für auskömmliche erklärt
hat obwohl der gegenüber Vorjahr um 140
Millionen Euro gekürzt wird das ist umso
überraschender als auch dich als auch
die vom Kabinett beschlossene
fachkräftestrategie der Bundesregierung
besagt das Zitat die berufsfachkurse
stärker gefördert und deren Mittel
verstehtätigt werden damit ist
insbesondere auch eine deutliche
Ausweitung der Sprachkurs Zugangs
verbunden Zitat Ende was ja auch Sinn
macht wenn im Oktober des Jahres allein
600 9000 € ukrainische StaatsbürgerInnen
bei der BA gemeldet waren für die ein
Integration in den Arbeitsmarkt
Förderangebote eine wichtige Hilfe sein
können es wird also weiter zu verfolgen
sein ob die nun vorgesehenen Mittel
tatsächlich ausreichend werden oder es
unterjährig eine ausstockung von über
planmäßigen Ausgabe Bedarf und wie sich
der Mittelabfluss auch in anderen
haushaltstiteln gestaltet
insgesamt setzt die Ampel mit diesem
Haushalt eine Reihe weiterer positive
Akzente unter anderem für die nationale
Armutskonferenz für die Umsetzung der
UN-Behindertenrechtskonvention sowie den
härtefallfonds jüdische
konvergenzflüchtlinge und Ost-
[Applaus]
das Wichtigste aber ist wir stellen
Weichen für das Bürgergeld und damit für
die größte Sozialreform seit Jahrzehnten
und das ist gut so
frank sirske war das für die Grünen
166,23 Milliarden Euro umfasst der
Etagen sozial ist das ist mehr als ein
Drittel des Gesamtetats des
Bundeshaushalts und 5,3 Milliarden Euro
zusätzlich zum vergangenen Jahr jetzt
Ottilie klein für die Union
fast jeder vierte über 80-jährige in
unserem Land ist von Armut betroffen die
Ampelkoalition das haben wir ja heute
auch wieder gehört die hält sich ja
gerne für soziale als alle anderen hat
aber auf Altersarmut überhaupt keine
Antworten denn wer ein Blick in den
Koalitionsvertrag wird der wird
feststellen dass Altersarmut mit keinem
einzigen Wort erwähnt wird
immerhin
immerhin erwähnt wird im
Koalitionsvertrag dass sie liebe
ampelfraktionen den unter
unionsgeführter Bundesregierung
geplanten härtefallfonds umsetzen wollen
der vorrichtet sich an Härtefälle aus
der
ost-rentenüberleitung Spätaussiedler und
jüdische zuwandererraum und seit
CDU-Fraktion war und ist es ein
Herzensanliegen die Menschen die sehr
kleine Renten beziehen zu unterstützen
deshalb hat die unionsgeführte Regierung
seinerzeit eine Milliarde Euro in den
Bundeshaushalt 2022 eingestellt
gemeinsam mit Ihnen liebe SPD gaben wir
den Betroffenen die jahrelang um
Anerkennung gekämpft haben das
Versprechen einer finanziellen Hilfe
leider mussten wir feststellen dass sie
ihr Wort gebrochen haben denn den
Beitrag des Bundes hat die Ampel um die
Hälfte gekürzt um 500 Millionen Euro
ausgerechnet
ausgerechnet in einer Zeit in der die
Menschen mit kleinen Renten besonders
belastet sind deshalb haben wir sie auch
aufgefordert die Streichung der Mittel
zurückzunehmen und den härtefallfonds
umzusetzen und das wissen wir und das
gehört zur Wahrheit dazu fast wäre der
härtefallfonds sogar ganz gescheitert
der eilig erstellte halbherzige
Vorschlag für den sie sich nun hier
feiern lassen ist für die Betroffenen
übrigens alles andere als feierlich im
Gegenteil ihre Pläne haben ihre Pläne
haben das Potenzial den Frust der
Betroffenen noch weiter zu erhöhen der
Beitrag bleibt hinter den Erwartungen
zurück eine Beteiligung der Länder ist
weiter unter die Fristen sind viel zu
kurz und sie bringen sogar fertig die
Gruppen gegeneinander auszuspielen und
ungleich zu behandeln das meine Damen
und Herren das ist respektlos gegenüber
der Lebensleistung der Menschen denn wir
dürfen nicht vergessen dieser Form die
ist auch Anerkennung und Gerechtigkeit
für jene Menschen die Benachteiligung
und Diskriminierung erfahren mussten
Menschen die aufgrund ihrer bewegten
Biografien nur sehr kleine Renten
erhalten und von Altersarmut bedroht
sind ihnen ein Stück weit Anerkennung zu
geben das war unser gemeinsames
versprechen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da auch im Haushalt 2023 die
Kürzung des bundesanteils nicht
zurückgenommen wurde halte ich fest dass
die Ampel dieses Versprechen gebrochen
hat und damit erneut unter Beweis stellt
dass ihr Altersarmut egal ist vielen
Dank
nächste Rednerin für die SPD-Fraktion dr
Tanja machalet
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
was wir jetzt in der Debatte wieder
feststellen konnten war dass die CDU
zwar immer wieder sagt wogegen sie ist
und was sie alles nicht wollen aber sie
haben man ganz wenigen Punkten gesagt
was sie tatsächlich wollen und das
durchzieht alle Debatten die wir bisher
haben das möchte ich nur noch mal
festhalten
und ich möchte auch noch mal deutlich
machen am Einzelplan 11 wird sehr
deutlich wie stark unsere Kolleginnen
und Kollegen im Haushaltsausschuss sich
ins Zeug gelegt haben um den guten
Entwurf noch besser zu machen und
als größter Einzelplan des gesamten
Bundeshaushalts spiegelt der die
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Sozialstaats
wieder und das ist gerade in dieser Zeit
ein ganz ganz wichtiges Signal
meine Kollegin Katrin michel hat es
treffen vorhin beschrieben Zusammenhalt
in der Zeitenwende bedeutet dass wir
gerade in Krisenzeiten in den
Sozialstaat investieren und wohl
überlegte Ausgaben für die soziale
Sicherung und ein stabilen Arbeitsmarkt
tätigen das ist ein schöner Ersatz und
den kann man glaube ich nicht oft genug
wiederholen im Sinne des Zusammenhalts
möchte ich natürlich auch an dieser
Stelle noch mal auf den Härtefall
Härtefall für Menschen aus der
ost-rentenüberleitung für jüdische
kontingenzflüchtlinge und spät
Aussiedler eingehen wir stellen im Bund
500 € 500 Millionen Euro zur Verfügung
besser wären natürlich eine Milliarde
ich bin im Haushaltsausschuss aber
dankbar dass es dass er das Gründen eine
Stiftung jetzt endlich ermöglicht mit
der wir nun endlich auszahlen können und
vor allem möchte ich
Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus Heil an
dieser Stelle nochmal danke dass Sie
sich in den vergangenen Jahren und
insbesondere auch der parlamentarischen
Staatssekretärin Krise dass sie sich
wirklich in den letzten Jahren intensiv
damit befasst haben und wirklich dafür
gekämpft haben das ganze endlich zum
Abschluss zu bringen
das Ministerium
ist jetzt schon bei der Umsetzung das
ist auch wichtig weil wir wissen die
Zeit drängt und ich möchte auch noch mal
an die Bundesländer appellieren die
Katrin michel hat vorhin auch getan
beteiligen Sie sich an den Fond die
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern das tut lieber
Kollege birkwald könnte außer ein Teil
dazu beitragen und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der CDU sie können auch
noch mal gerne mit ihren Ministerinnen
Ministerpräsidenten sprechen das ich gut
ist ich spreche auch mit meiner
Ministerpräsidentin sie können das auch
tun vielleicht kommen die Länder ja noch
zu dem Schluss dass es durchaus auch
ihre Aufgabe ist sich an diesem Fond zu
beteiligen
zum Bürgergeld ist ja nun eine denke ich
alles diskutiert wir werden es morgen
beschließen ich möchte aber trotzdem
noch mal einen Satz dazu sagen und zwar
ein Zitat von Regine Hildebrandt die
übermorgen leider schon seit 21 Jahren
tot ist sie hat gesagt und ich zitiere
mit Erlaubnis der Präsidentin aber kurz
ein Alltag ohne soziale Demütigung das
ist das Grundrecht aller ausnahmslos das
ist unsere Haltung das bleibt unsere
Haltung und das ist genau das was uns
von Ihnen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der CDU und insbesondere von Ihnen Herr
Merz unterscheidet herzlichen Dank
nächster Redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
Axel knörick und Axel köring für die
cdu/csu ist der letzte Redner hier beim
Einsparen 11 Arbeit und
sozialisen meine sehr verehrten Damen
und Herren
Herr Kollege alt
ein Christdemokraten das christliche
Menschenbild abzusprechen
und das noch zu verbinden mit einem
Vokabular wir sein Regeln für
ich finde das einfach eine bescheidene
Debattenkultur
und mein lieber Kollege Frank Zierke
wir schätzen uns und ich sag mal
das war auch kein glorreicher Anfang
weiß Gott nicht da geh mal bitte in dich
Herr Minister Herr Heil sie haben
begonnen ihre Rede mit der Zeitenwende
sie haben hier auf von Auswirkungen
gesprochen und die Frage Sie Herr
bündeln Bundesminister für Arbeit und
Soziales wo bleiben eigentlich die
Konsequenzen der Zeitenwende in ihrem
Verantwortungsbereich
und da sehe ich doch nur altbekannte
Reflexe immer wenn es Probleme gibt da
werden die mit Geld verdeckt und da
sagen wir als Union ganz klar das ist
nicht unsere Zeiten wenn der wenn sie
sagen eine Lizenz zur Aufblähung des
Sozialstaat wir sagen und das zu
Unterschied wir lösen Probleme gezielt
anstatt durch immer höhere
Sozialausgaben diese zu verdecken es
müssen diejenigen gezielt unterstützt
werden die tatsächlich Unterstützung
benötigen
und da will ich auf ein Thema eingehen
und da hat die FDP heute gut vorgelegt
mit Frau raffelhüchen das ist die
Rentenreform
oder wollen wir
Generationengerechtigkeit herstellen und
auch gleichzeitig eine angemessene
Altersvorsorgung aus sicherstellen und
da haben die Rentner profitiert von den
Erhöhungen und das wird auch bis 2026
gut weitergehen und ich erinnere hier an
die 16 Jahre
wo wir die rettenkasse fortlaufend gut
angefüllt haben und ich sage hier auch
noch mal in aller Deutlichkeit mit Blick
auf zu neuen und zwei zehn beginnend mit
der Kurzarbeit die wir auch in den
letzten Jahren gut angesetzt haben dass
hier viele Arbeitsplätze gesichert
werden konnten und das ist auch der
rettenversicherung zu Gute gekommen ich
sage
unser Rentensystem ist noch Leistungs
und deswegen brauchen wir zügig eine
Debatte wie die Rente in Zukunft
aussehen soll aktuell kommen auf einem
Rentner zwei Arbeiten immer wir wissen
dass in 2050 dieses Verhältnis auf eins
zu eins sich angreifen und deswegen ist
der Vorschlag der FDP zu aktienrente das
ein richtiger Gedanke aber wir sagen das
Volumen ist zu klein sie wissen ja wir
geben jährlich 340 Milliarden Euro aus
an die Rentenbezieher und wenn sie da 10
Milliarden nach dem dritten Haushalt
jetzt einstellen ist das schlichtweg zu
wenig
auch der Vorschlag von der SPD das
Rentenniveau dauerhaft festzulegen es
keine Lösung das ist wie wir sagen du
Vogel Strauß Politik ein verdecken von
Wirklichkeiten und vor allem ein
wecktuten vor Verantwortung es ist doch
gerade eine Belastung für die jüngeren
Generation die das schlichtweg nicht
schultern können und ich sage deswegen
wir müssen alle drei Pfeiler der
Altersvorsorge weiterentwickeln und da
müssen neue Ideen auf dem Tisch wie die
gesamte Bevölkerung bei dieser wichtigen
Frage ordentlich mitgenommen wird denn
wir arbeitet er wird Leistungsansprüche
und erhält dadurch weniger oder gar
keine Transferleistung und wir sagen
immer wieder arbeiten muss sich lohnen
und Rente ist nun für Lebensleistung und
das sollte auch gerade der Grundstock
sein für die kommende Reform des
rettensystems
wir haben in die vergangenen Jahren auch
gerade bei Geringverdienern die
Betriebsrente gestärkt und ich muss
sagen für jeden Arbeitnehmer sollte es
zukünftig eine Betriebsräte geben und
wir brauchen ein neues Finanzprodukt für
die Altersvorsorge das gerade für
Beschäftigten für kleineinkommen auch
attraktiv ist und das meine ich das sind
nachhaltige Konzepte die den Menschen in
unserem Land aus Sicherheit geben und da
fehlen die zukunftsorientierten Ideen er
heilen sie haben das selbst gesagt dass
gerade die Arbeit doch das Wichtigste
ist dass viele Menschen Arbeit haben
sollten und deswegen korrigieren wir
beim Bürgergeld und das haben wir
gemacht das hat auch die Einigung
gezeigt dass die Vermittlung in den
Arbeitsmarkt im Zentrum der Reform steht
und wir können das Sehen beim Bürgergeld
und auch bei der energiepreispauschale
die wir ja für die Rentner auch für die
Studenten immer wieder gefordert haben
und auch erreicht haben in den letzten
Wochen es kommt bessere Ergebnisse
zustande wenn die Union mit und ich sage
ganz laut und deutlich wir sind das
Korrektiv der Mitte deshalb fordere ich
Sie auf eröffnen Sie die Diskussion Herr
Minister um die Rente
ja und das war es und zur Rente schnell
der Nachtrag
112,39 Milliarden Euro fließen in die
Rente von den
166,23 Milliarden die der Einzelplan elf
umfasst hierzu liegt ein Änderungsantrag
der Fraktion der cdu/csu auf Drucksache
4547 vor bestimmt zuerst über diesen
Änderungsantrag ab wer stimmt für diesen
Änderungsantrag
ich nehme an das ist die
cdu/csu-fraktion
und die Fraktion DIE LINKE wer stimmt
dagegen in der Tat ist es ein
Änderungsantrag der
cdu/csu und sie verlangen mehr Geld für
die Servicestellen jugendagenturen
dann kommen wir jetzt zur Abstimmung
über den Einzelplan 11 in der
ausschussfassung wer stimmt
das sind die Fraktionen der SPD Bündnis
90 die Grünen und FDP wer stimmt dagegen
das ist die Fraktion Die Linke cdu/csu
und afd-fraktion Enthaltung sehe ich
nicht der Einzelplan 11 ist damit
angenommen
ich rufe nun auf den Einzelplan 15
Bundesministerium für Gesundheit
mit den Beschlussempfehlungen des
Haushaltsausschusses auf Drucksachen
3.514 und 3.500
mit dem morgigen Tag wird das leidige
Thema Hartz IV erledigt sein man kann
darüber diskutieren ob das Bürgergeld
die Fortsetzung ist oder eine
substanzielle Veränderung darstellt
jedenfalls wird es morgen den Bundestag
passieren können und dann den Bundesrat
und am ersten
wird dann das Bürgergeld in Kraft treten
aber es geht jetzt bereits hier fliegen
weiter Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit ist
aufgerufen worden von Karl Lauterbach
das er hat nur noch 24,5 Milliarden Euro
zur Verfügung im vergangenen Jahr waren
es
64,36 Milliarden warum dieses Minus ganz
logisch da ging es um die Bekämpfung der
Pandemie
30,08 Milliarden im vergangenen Jahr und
in diesem Jahr sind für die Corona
Folgen 1,2 Milliarden noch eingeplant
und der erste Redner ist der Vorsitzende
des Haushaltsausschusses hell gebrauen
von der CDU und Kollegen wir beraten den
Einzelplan des Bundesministeriums für
Gesundheit und der größte Posten ist
traditionell der Zuschuss zur
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung erhält
in dem kommenden Jahr neben dem
standardzuschuss weitere zwei Milliarden
Euro und darüber hinaus wird es trotzdem
erforderlich sein dass der
Krankenversicherungsbeitrag wir reden ja
eigentlich in diesen Tagen in diesem
Haus sehr viel darüber dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger entlastet werden
müssen der durchschnittliche
Krankenversicherungsbeitrag wird zum
kommenden Jahr um 0,3 Prozent steigen
das heißt die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
werden nicht mehr sondern weniger Netto
vom Brutto haben und das macht zum
ersten deutlich dass die GKV
finanzstabilisierung die im Gesetz des
Bundesministers vorgesehenes eigentlich
nur ein marginal Teil beiträgt der
Bundeshaushalt muss mehr leisten und die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger müssen mehr
leisten die
gkv-finanzstabilisierung bleibt weit
hinter dem zurück was eigentlich
erforderlich ist
große Sorgen haben in diesen Tagen die
Krankenhäuser der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat selber in
seiner letzten Rede hier darauf
hingewiesen dass bereits 40 Prozent
unserer Krankenhäuser
Liquiditätsprobleme haben und deshalb
hat eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch
angekündigt dass es ein härtefallfonds
geben soll sechs Milliarden im kommenden
und zwei Milliarden im Jahr 2024 die den
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
bei den Energiepreisen helfen soll bis
heute liegt uns nichts vor
Krankenhäuser denken darüber nach ob sie
jetzt eigentlich Insolvenz anmelden
müssen oder ob sie sozusagen in der
Erwartung auf diese Hilfe von der weder
klar ist für welchen Zeitraum sie
gewährt wird noch in welcher Höhe sie
gewährt wird ob Sie darauf vertrauen
können und weitermachen können oder ob
sie sich eigentlich der fortgesetzten
Insolvenzverschleppung irgendwie
schuldig machen und deshalb ist es
allerhöchste Zeit dass die Ampel die
ihren Streit über die Frage ob das
Wirtschafts Ministerium oder das
Gesundheitsministerium das ganze
administriert beilegt sondern den
Krankenhäusern und Pflegeeinrichtungen
und Deutschland Gewissheit gibt in
welcher Höhe Sie von diesem Fond
profitieren können denn nach dem
Belastungen der letzten Jahre die die
Krankenhäuser hatten haben sie
Planungssicherheit verdient und nicht
diese fortgesetzte Untätigkeit durch den
Streit in der Ampel
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen mit dem
Haushaltsentwurf den die Bundesregierung
vorgelegt hat hat sie sehr klar gesagt
für uns ist Corona erledigt und hat
zunächst an vielen Stellen keine Kosten
mehr vorgesehen wir haben jetzt eine
Situation wo wir schon heute im
Haushaltsausschuss gesehen haben dass
selbstverständlich im nächsten Jahr über
die testverordnung weitere Ausgaben
erforderlich sind und deshalb ist der
eigentliche Sparstrumpf nämlich die
globale Mehrausgabe die der
Finanzminister eigentlich
verunsicherheiten im nächsten Jahr
vorhalten wollte auch schon angeknabbert
mit 1,2 Milliarden für Testen im
nächsten Jahr das heißt auch hier ist
nicht ausreichend Vorsorge betroffen
worden was mich aber ehrlich gesagt am
meisten mit Sorge erfüllt ist worauf ich
in vielen Gesprächen auch hingewiesen
habe das im Haushalt des nächsten Jahr
drei Milliarden Euro vorgesehen sind für
Impfstoff Ankäufe für Corona
das ist die Folge aus den Verträgen die
die Europäische Kommission gemacht hat
und wenn man das umrechnet sind das
ungefähr 150 Millionen Impfstoffdosen im
nächsten Jahr wir könnten also 90
Prozent der Bevölkerung nächstes Jahr
damit zweimal durchimpfen in diesem
Verträgen sind wir gebunden und diese
Verträge damals am Beginn der Pandemie
zu machen damit mich da keiner falsch
versteht war richtig aber jetzt ist es
notwendig dass die Bundesregierung auf
die Europäische Kommission und die
Hersteller zugeht und eine deutliche
Flexibilisierung in diesen Verträgen
erreicht weil wenn wir in dieser
Größenordnung im nächsten Jahr
Impfstoffe kaufen dann ist bereits jetzt
absehbar dass wir mit großer
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass allermeiste
davon vernichten müssen und das ist
nicht nur eine finanzpolitische
Katastrophe sondern das wäre auch
unethisch in Hinblick auf die Ressourcen
wieder eingesetzt werden
was die ich ausdrücklich begrüße ist
dass die Ampelkoalition und auch vieles
davon haben wir in Anträgen deutlich
gemacht an einigen Stellen diesen
Haushalt deutlich verbessert was ich zum
Beispiel nicht verstanden habe ist dass
die Regierung angesichts der Tatsache
dass sie sich auf den Weg macht
Haschisch zu legalisieren gleichzeitig
im Bereich der Drogenprävention eine
deutliche Absenkung des Titels
vorgesehen hat und da haben wir uns mehr
vorgestellt aber es ist richtig dass die
Koalition an der Stelle auch etwas tut
und wir würde den die Veränderungen im
Haushalt im Parlament jetzt wieder mehr
Geld für die Prävention im Drogenbereich
ausgeht
etwas was mich nach wie vor aber sehr
beschwert ist der Punkt dass das Thema
globale Gesundheit gerade jetzt im
Ausgang der Pandemie eines der größten
und wichtigsten Themen ist die wir
international haben das Thema ist unter
Druck Donald Trump mit seinem Versuch
Ausstieg aus der WHO hat die
internationale Gesundheit unter Druck
gesetzt auch Boris johnson war ein ein
Regierungschef der die Ausgaben in dem
Bereich zurückgefahren hat und das ist
jetzt diese Bundesregierung ist die
einen Entwurf vorliegt wo die Ausgaben
für die internationale Gesundheit um 70
Prozent abgesenkt werden das ist ein
fatales Signal in die öffentliche
Community das ist falsch und hier sitzen
viele die mit mir im Ausschuss unter
Ausschuss globale Gesundheit sind sowas
dürfen wir eigentlich nicht tun und ich
bin froh und sage auch danke dafür dass
die Koalition zumindest bei jungen Aids
und beim global hat kleine Korrekturen
vorgenommen hat also gar nicht verstehe
ist dass unser Flaggschiff der World
Health Summit wurde letztes Mal die
Ampelkoalition noch gesagt hat das
stocken wir auf jetzt die Kürzung dieses
Gesundheitsministers wieder hingenommen
hat das ist falsch globale gesundheit
ist ein zentrales Zukunftsthema da haben
wir internationale Verantwortung und
deshalb können wir in der Summe diesem
Einzelplan so leider nicht zustimmen
Helge braun ist auf der Berichterstatter
der cdu/csu er war hier der erste Redner
zum Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit und
Wolfgang Kubicki hat mittlerweile das
Präsidium übernommen und hat jetzt
angekündigt die nächste Rednerin Svenja
Stadler die berichterstatt drin der
SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
für den Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Gäste auf
den Tribünen und vor den Bildschirmen
als erstes möchte ich mich bedanken ich
möchte mich bedanken bei den
mitberichterstattern und vor allen
Dingen bei Paula picchiotta und Carsten
klein für die konstruktive und vor allen
Dingen vertrauensvolle Zusammenarbeit in
dieser Zeit das ist nicht einfach
gewesen und deshalb danke da und auch
natürlich an die Mitarbeiterinnen und
Mitarbeiter denn ohne dass wir es und
wie wäre es überhaupt gar nicht möglich
gewesen denn wir stehen ja vor nicht
ganz so einfachen Zeiten die
finanziellen Spielräume sind verdammt
eng und dann ist es für uns Haushälter
besonders schwer und wir gucken sehr
intensiv auf die einzelnen
Haushaltstitel und vor allen Dingen auch
Projekte und hinterfragen an der einen
oder anderen Stelle auch diese Projekte
und schauen ob sie ihre Ziele überhaupt
eingehalten haben und das bedeutet
dass wir auch verstärkt Fragen an das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium gestellt
haben und deshalb auch an dieser Stelle
ein herzliches Dankeschön an das Haus
und auch an Karl Lauterbach denn die
Fragen wurden zügig beantwortet und das
ist gut
der freundlich fragt bekommt gute
Antworten vielleicht sollten sie mal
daran arbeiten
und das hat dazu geführt dass es eben in
den
Haushaltsberatungen verdammt viele
Änderungsanträge für den Etat 2023 bis
Bundesgesundheitsministeriums gegeben
hat und wir haben wesentlich reduziert
und gleichzeitig viel Schwerpunkte
gestellt bzw gesetzt insgesamt ist der
Italien Haushaltsverhandlungen auf 24,5
Milliarden Euro gestiegen es hat vor
allen Dingen mit den Leistungen des
Bundes an den Gesundheitsfonds für die
von der Pandemie verursachten
Belastungen und den Zuschüssen zur
impfstoffbeschaffung zu tun das sind
Kosten von knapp 2,4 Milliarden Euro
nachgefallen Schwerpunkt auch in diesem
Haushalt wir in der
fortschrittskoalition haben zudem in den
Bereichen Digitalisierung
Gesundheitsprävention und der
internationalen Gesundheit mehr Geld
eingesetzt und damit haben wir gerade
die Umsetzung zentraler Punkte die im
Koalitionsvertrag vorgesehen sind
angeschoben
die Mittel für die Digitalisierung
konnten wir erhöhen dadurch kann die
Versorgungsqualität verbessert
Arbeitsabläufe effizienter gestaltet und
Personal entlastet werden das was wir
jetzt in die Digitalisierung investieren
insbesondere in die Vorhabenplanung und
den strukturprozess wird nachgelagerte
Vorgänge entlasten und damit auch Kosten
sparen deshalb sind die 5 Millionen Euro
zur Förderung der digitalen
Transformation eine gute Investition in
die Zukunft eine weitere Million ist für
das Notaufnahme Register vorgesehen und
dann gibt es da ja noch das Thema
Konnektoren ein sehr spannendes Thema
Berichterstattungen haben wir ja lesen
können dazu und mir ist es tatsächlich
ein Rätsel wie man Verträge abschließen
kann in denen steht dass ein
unabwendbarer Tausch von Konnektoren
notwendig ist und das ist für die
Zukunft finde ich nicht zielführend und
deshalb bin ich dankbar dass das Haus
eine lö mit Sicherheit
entwickeln wird das zukünftig
Datenschutz berücksichtigt und
gleichzeitig diesen Tausch nicht mehr
notwendig macht das ist gut für die
Natur für die Nachhaltigkeit und es
sinnvoll und ich weiß auch dass unser
Minister an diesen Verträgen nicht
beteiligt war ich könnte mir vorstellen
wer es war ich habe jetzt über das
Budget gesprochen
noch ein
ige Bereiche Digitalisierung mein
Kollege Matthias spricht ja nach mir ich
kann mir vorstellen dass er darauf noch
näher eingehen wird ein weiteren
Schwerpunkt haben wir in der Prävention
und der Aufklärung gerade im Hinblick
auf die Legalisierung von Cannabis und
deshalb haben wir die Kürzungen
rückgängig gemacht und den Titel wieder
auf das ursprüngliche Niveau
zurückgesetzt 13,2 Millionen Euro das
ist wichtig und ich finde jetzt haben
wir zum zweiten Mal sehr deutlich
signalisiert was der Parlaments Wille
ist und ich erwarte im Regierungsentwurf
2024 dass die dieser Titel mindestens
bei 13,2 Millionen liegt gerne höher
im Zusammenhang mit der gesundheitlichen
Aufklärung der Bevölkerung haben wir
außerdem den nationalen präventionsplan
mit 850.000 Euro unterlegt den Zuschuss
an den Verein Aktion psychisch Kranke
konnten wir
150.000 Euro erhöhen das ist wichtig
damit der Psychiatrie Dialog fortgeführt
wird der wichtige und wertvolle Impulse
zur Weiterentwicklung des
versorgungsangebotes gibt
schließlich
haben wir uns auch die Suizidprävention
angeschaut es gibt da definitiv Dinge
die man nutzen kann Synergien nutzen
kann wir haben das Haus damit einen
kleinen Hausaufgabe gegeben ich bin auf
den Bericht gespannt schließlich haben
wir ampelhaushälter im Bereich globale
Gesundheit Herr Braun hatte das ja
gerade auch schon einmal angeführt noch
mal deutlicher Mittel Aufstockungen im
Vergleich zum Regierungsentwurf
durchgesetzt
3,75 Millionen Euro sollen als Zuschuss
eigentlich fließen und eine Million eben
noch mal an den global Hels hat ja wir
wissen mehr ist immer besser aber bei
einem so engen Haushalt ist es verdammt
schwierig vielleicht haben wir nächstes
und über nächstes Jahr mehr
Möglichkeiten
insgesamt bleibt zu sagen dass wir im
Jahr 2023 große strukturelle
Herausforderungen im Gesundheits- und
Pflegesystem vor uns haben ich bin davon
überzeugt dass wir mit dem jetzigen
Haushalt eine solide Grundlage dafür
geschaffen haben die kommenden Ausgaben
zu meistern mit diesem Haushalt leisten
wir unseren Gesundheits politischen
Beitrag für den Zusammenhalt in der
Zeitenwende und daher können sie einfach
nur zustimmen ich tu's danke schön
vielen Dank
dass die Berichterstatterin der SPD dem
Haushalt zustimmen wird nächster Redner
in der Debatte ist der
gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der AFD
Martin sichert
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
bettlägerige Senioren liegen stundenlang
hilflos in ihren eigenen Fäkalien ein
Verstorbener Licht tagelang im Bett
einen anderen Sterbenden erreicht der
Notarzt nicht weil er nicht ins Haus
kommt was wie Apokalypse klingt ist
diesen Monat in einem Seniorenheim in
Marburg Realität ein Pfleger sagt dazu
ich zitiere das Haus steht in Flammen es
geht nichts mehr keiner von uns egal ob
mit oder ohne Symptome in Quarantäne
darf mehr rein und sich um die alten
Menschen kümmern
gesunde Pflegekräfte dürfen wegen der
Politik dieser Bundesregierung nicht
arbeiten und müssen die Hochbetagten
Senioren völlig würdelos einsam in ihren
stinkenden Exkrementen liegen lassen
menschenverachtender als die Zustände in
diesem Heim ist nur noch die Politik
ihrer Bundesregierung
richtig sie haben keinen Respekt vor dem
Pflegekräften das sagen sie ganz richtig
sie rauben den Hochbetagten Senioren
ihren Angehörigen und auch den
Pflegekräften die würde schämen sie sich
ja Lauterbach schämen sie sich
[Applaus]
für über 10.000 neue Stellen in Behörden
hat die Ampel Geld im Gesundheitswesen
hingegen bestraft man die dringend
benötigten Fachkräfte allein in Jena
bekommen diese Tage
654 ungeimpfte Mitarbeiter im
Gesundheitswesen Bußgeldbescheide über
jeweils 250 Euro Strafe und warum nur
weil sie die völlig unsinnige
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht
eingeführt haben von der sie inzwischen
selbstabstand nehmen aber sie ist nun
mal noch in Kraft und richtet weiter
Schaden an obwohl wir von der AFD als
einzige von Anfang an davor gewarnt
haben
Zwischenfrage aus der Fraktion DIE LINKE
Frage bitte schön
Herr Kollege sichert nehmen Sie zur
Kenntnis dass die Stadt Jena sämtliche
Bußgeldbescheide zurückgenommen wird und
dass diese nicht versendet werden sie
auf erzählen hier Unwahrheiten
die Stadt Jena hat vor zwei Tagen noch
in der Presse verkündet dass sie
entsprechend diese Bußgeldbescheide
raussenden wird und dass man diese Leute
so unfassbar in der Unsicherheit lässt
ob sie jetzt Bußgeldbescheide bekommen
oder ob sie keine Bußgeldbescheide
bekommen das Anfragen der Stadt Jena bei
der Landesregierung dazu geführt haben
dass die dort die Informationen bekommen
hat naja sie sollen doch ca ein Zehntel
des Möglichen Bußgeld von 2500 250 € den
Leuten geben und dass man dann gesagt
hat na ja dann geben das den Leuten halt
dann vielleicht im März und nicht jetzt
Weihnachten sie führen mit ihrer Politik
dieser Ampel Politik Ampel führt mit
ihrer Politik zu einem absoluten Chaos
und sie führt dazu dass die Leute
verunsichert sind und wir haben viele
Fälle bundesweit wo tatsächlich
Bußgelder auch verhängt worden sind wo
Leute bestraft worden sind und zwar
nicht nur im Gesundheitswesen sondern
auch bei der Bundeswehr wo wir immer
noch diese ganzen Probleme haben hören
Sie endlich auf die ungeimpften Menschen
in diesem Land zu dringend hören sie auf
mit der Diskriminierung
deutschland braucht nicht noch mehr
Bürokraten die aktenstapelwelsen sondern
deutschland braucht mehr Menschen die
bereit sind anzupacken die meisten von
uns werden irgendwann mal alt oder krank
sein und dann ist es völlig egal wie
viele Amtsschimmel Viren was dann zählt
ist die viele Pflegekräfte Ärzte und
andere Menschen in Heilberufen da sind
um uns zu helfen mein Vorschlag stampfen
sie tausend ihrer neuen Stellen ein und
bezahlen Sie damit alle Bußgelder der
von ihnen nun über zwei Jahren
drangsalierten ungeimpften Fachkräfte
und der ungeimpften Soldaten
19% Übersterblichkeit hatten wir allein
im Oktober auch in den Monaten davor gab
es deutliche Übersterblichkeit in einem
sind die Experten sich einig nämlich
dass diese Übersterblichkeit andere
Ursachen als Corona haben muss die
Bundesregierung unternimmt nichts um das
zu untersuchen und auch im Haushalt für
nächstes Jahr sind keine Gelder dafür
vorgesehen es könnten ja schließlich
unangenehme Ergebnisse dabei
herauskommen nicht wahr es ist zutiefst
beschämend Herr Lauterbach wie sie sich
vor ihrer Verantwortung wegducken
200 Millionen für eine unnütze waren App
hunderte Millionen Werbung für nur an
Mäusen getestete Impfstoffe und aber
Milliarden für Masken und Impfstoffe
dafür Bargeld da und dafür ist Geld da
in der Gesundheitsversorgung hingegen
fehlt ist viele Arztpraxen und
Facharztpraxen stehen vor dem Aus wegen
Energiekosten Inflation und dem hohen
Alter der Ärzte dabei müssen viele
Patienten jetzt schon auf Ortstermine
viele Monate warten wie wird das erst in
Zukunft werden und noch schlimmer sieht
bei den Hebammen aus die sie absolut
stiefmütterlich behandeln um deinen
fehlen zehntausende Fachkräfte egal ob
Sie Herr Lauterbach oder ihr
Amtsvorgänger sparen viel zu lange wurde
Geld vor allem investiert um die
Ideologie der Regierenden und die
Interessen der Lobbyisten zu befriedigen
damit muss Schluss sein
nicht die Menschen müssen der Politik
dienen sondern die Politik muss endlich
wieder den Menschen dienen und weil
dieser Haushalt nicht den Menschen dient
sondern die Politikern und den
Lobbyisten lehnen wir Ihnen ab
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
der Bundestag debattiert über den
Einzelplan 15 Gesundheit mit
24,5 Milliarden Euro gibt es deutlich
weniger Geld als im vergangenen Jahr da
waren es noch 64,36 Milliarden die
Folgen der Pandemie in diesem Jahr muss
ich sagen ich im letzten mit 64,36 im
kommenden soll es dann 24,5 geben so ist
es richtig so und die nächste Rednerin
ist Paul API Schotter von den Grünen
nach diesen negativ Beispiel vielen
lieben Dank Herr gebraun sein Kinder hat
am Anfang der Woche gesagt dass man die
Union in der Opposition manchmal nicht
versteht gerade auch was
haushaltsklarheit und Wahrheit angeht
für den Einzelplan 15 muss man sagen wir
verstehen sie sehr gut und wir finden
das als sehr konstruktive Opposition die
sind in dem Bereich wahrnehmen und
deswegen an der Stelle groß und dann
kann sie aber auch natürlich an alle
meine mit berichter insbesondere auch
wenn der Stadler und Carsten klein wir
haben uns ja heute auch aus Versehen
farblich abgesprochen so gut
funktioniert die Ampel im Einzelhandel
ich habe in den letzten Wochen ich habe
in den letzten Wochen versucht die
Realität der Deckblätter während der
haushaltsverhandlung zum Einzelplan 15
mit der Realität vor Ort im
Gesundheitswesen in Einklang zu bringen
und immer wieder miteinander
abzugleichen ich war deswegen viel
unterwegs auch in den Kliniken meiner
Region sehr unterschiedliche Ostsachsen
Westsachsen kleine Häuser und große
Häuser teilweise in kirchlicher
teilweise im privater Trägerschaft und
man würde ja denken dass in dieser Zeit
wo ganz Deutschland übersteigende
Energiepreise und Inflation redet dass
das auch das dringendste Thema in den
Kliniken wäre aber das war tatsächlich
nicht so weil der Fachkräftemangel im
Gesundheitswesen so eklatant ist dass er
selbst aktuell die Frage der Inflation
und Energiepreise überstrahlt Kliniken
die teilweise inzwischen ihr Personal so
stark zentralisieren müssen
zusammenziehen müssen im op-trag damit
wenigstens der OP Betrieb läuft wo wir
früher Probleme hatten Patienten in die
Anschlussbehandlung in die Pflege weiter
zu entlassen ist inzwischen nicht mal
mehr die Pflege dass das Nadelöhr
sondern der Krankentransport der die
Patientinnen und Patienten zu
transportieren könnte in einzelnen
Kliniken meiner Region der
Fachkräftemangel ist das eklatanteste
Problem weiterhin im Gesundheitswesen
auch in diesem Jahr und da werden Ihnen
alle Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter
auch bestätigen dass es nicht nur eine
Frage des Geldes und es wird vor allen
Dingen auch daran deutlich
dass wir ja in den letzten drei Jahren
erheblicher zusätzliche Gelder in die
Kliniken gesteckt haben wenn wir die
letzten drei Jahre zusammen nehmen mit
den Krankenhaus Ausgleichszahlungen den
intensivbettenförderung und den
versorgungszuschlägen
22,233 Milliarden on top für die
deutschen Kliniken und das wird auch da
wird auch so ein bisschen deutlich das
Ende des Lösungsansatzes mehr Geld für
strukturelle Probleme im
Gesundheitswesen wenn man sieht dass
trotz dieser 22 Milliarden kein einziges
Problem im Klinikbereich gelöst ist nach
diesen drei Jahren sondern wir jetzt
nach den letzten drei Jahren ins nächste
Jahr gehen und jetzt den härtefallfond
für die Kliniken auflegen noch mal bis
zu 10 Milliarden weil einfach
grundlegende strukturelle Probleme im
Klinikbereich nicht gelöst sind meine
Damen und Herren
dieser härtefallfond ist im Einzelplan
60 angesetzt und wir fanden es aber als
Berichterstatter im Gesundheitsbereich
unglaublich wichtig den mit einer
Maßgabe zu versehen denn dieser
Härtefall ist notwendig weil die Länder
in den letzten Jahren strukturell ihre
Kliniken unterfinanziert haben die
krankenhausinvestitionskosten
Finanzierung jedes Jahr geschätzt 4
Milliarden die die Länder dort nicht zur
Verfügung stellen und die deswegen nicht
vorhandene Gebäude Modernisierung die
deswegen nicht vorhandene
energieeffizienz ist ja eine
Voraussetzung dafür dass wir jetzt in
dieser aktuellen Situation der
notwendigen größeren Energieeffizienz
der hohen Energiepreise überhaupt als
Bund wieder die Lücken füllen müssen die
teilweise die Länder gerissen haben und
das ist keine nachhaltiger Lösungsansatz
und deswegen haben wir auch als
Haushaltsausschuss mit guter Mehrheit
dem der Bundesregierung jetzt mitgegeben
dass Sie sofort den Gesprächen mit den
Ländern eintreten muss und sofort
Programme aufzulegen zur energetischen
Sanierung denn wir müssen hier nicht nur
als Haushaltsausschuss des Bundestages
sondern dann auch als Patientinnen und
als beschäftigt im Gesundheitswesen den
Ländern zutrauen was die Länder sich
selber nicht zutrauen nämlich ihre
eigenen Aufgaben endlich auch suffizient
wahrzunehmen meine Damen und Herren
denn zur Wahrheit gehört auch
denn zur Wahrheit gehört auch wenn wir
uns die gesamte Ausgaben und
Gesundheitswesen anschauen zum Beispiel
wie sie dieses Jahr für 2020
veröffentlicht wurden knapp 441
Milliarden Euro die das Gesundheitswesen
in Deutschland dieses Jahr umsetzt das
ist fast so groß wie ein gesamter
Bundeshaushalt auch in diesen Zeiten und
das macht auch deutlich wie begrenzt an
der Stelle auch die Möglichkeiten eines
einzelnen Akteurs wie zum Beispiel des
Bundes sind der Bund kann nicht allein
mit Mitteln des Bundeshaushalts die
schwerwiegenden strukturellen Probleme
im Gesundheitswesen lösen wir können
auch hier nur Symptome Linderung machen
wir kommen an den grundlegenden
strukturellen Form auf allen Ebenen auch
mit den Ländern auch mit den Kommunen
und vor allen Dingen auch mit der
Selbstverwaltung Gesundheitswesen
einfach nicht vorbei sonst werden wir
jedes Jahr nur weiter Symptome Linderung
machen die sehr teuer ist und aber keine
Probleme grundlegend
jetzt lassen Sie mich noch kurz einzelne
kleine schlaglichte auf kleinere
Projekte werfen die wir auch im
Einzelplan 15 angesprochen haben Svenja
Stadler hat dankenswerterweise schon
einige genannt ich möchte noch die
longkowith Beratung ergänzen viele
Patientinnen und Patienten sind gerade
sehr stark davon
beeindruckt wie viele Informationen über
longkow wird im Umlauf sind die
teilweise auch schwer für Patientinnen
und Patienten überprüfbar sind hier
stärken wir die neutrale Fakten basierte
Beratung für den Übergangszeit bis das
Gesundheitswesen das selber vollständig
auffangen kann wir stärken wie es wenn
ja Stahl der richtigerweise gesagt hat
Jonen Aids und den global Farb wir
stärken auch den nationalen
präventionsplan und ja
wir haben und das bin ich an der Stelle
bin ich auch der Union und der
Linkspartei sehr dankbar mit fast
einstimmiger Einstimmigkeit die
Kürzungen im Bereich Suchtberatung die
das Bundesgesundheitsministerium
unerklärlicherweise wieder reduziert
hatte vollständig zurückgenommen der
Haushaltsausschuss hat hier zwischen
Opposition und Koalition sehr klar
gemacht dass er das als eine extrem
wichtige und zentrale Aufgabe gerade
auch nach der Pandemie und gerade auch
in Zeiten der Cannabis Legalisierung
ansieht vielen vielen herzlichen Dank
auch an Helge braun und gesehene
Geld ist wichtig aber es ist nicht alles
das wird in jeder Mitarbeiter und jeder
Patient im Gesundheitswesen
bestätigen und ich freue mich dass wir
im nächsten Jahr in dieser guten
Konstruktivität die wir in den Beratung
des Einzelplans 15 haben uns auch daran
machen das Gesundheitswesen und die
Pflegeversicherung tatsächlich jetzt
endlich auf sehr viel stabilere Füße für
die kommenden Jahre zu stellen vielen
herzlichen Dank
war auch die Berichterstatterin für die
Bündnisgrünen für den Eisbahn 15
Gesundheit und Gesine Lötstelle
vertretender Fraktionsvorsitzende Linke
ist auch Berichterstatterin für ihre
Fraktionen für den Bereich Gesundheit
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren Karl
Lauterbach will nun als knallharter
Sanierer auftreten ich sage Ihnen aber
wir brauchen keinen Minister der unser
Gesundheitssystem auf noch mehr Profit
trimmt wir brauchen ein
Gesundheitsminister der dafür sorgt dass
kranke Menschen ordentlich versorgt
werden meine Damen und Herren
nun hat es der Sozialdemokrat Lauterbach
auf die Hebammen abgesehen die Hebammen
sollen nicht mehr von den Krankenkassen
finanziert werden sondern von den
Krankenhäusern den Krankenhäusern steht
aber das Wasser bis zum Hals sie sollen
in den kommenden zwei Jahren nur sechs
Milliarden Euro als Inflationsausgleich
erhalten Sie brauchen aber 15 Milliarden
um überleben zu können und nun sollen
diese Hebammen zwischen Krankenkassen
und Krankenhäusern zerrieben werden das
darf nicht geschehen meine Damen und
Herren eine Petition gegen diese
verwerfliche Idee wurde von 1,2
Millionen Menschen unterschrieben und
nun kam Herr Lauterbach zu der
erstaunlichen Erkenntnis der
wirtschaftliche Druck vertragen sich
nicht mit dem Berufsbild ich frage sie
verträgt sich wirtschaftlicher Druck mit
dem Berufsbild der Krankenschwester oder
der Ärztin nein sagen wir Gesundheit und
Profitmacherei müssen sich ausschließen
meine Damen und Herren
immer mehr Kinderärzte berichten mir
dass sie keine neuen Patienten mehr
aufnehmen können ein Arzt aus meinem
Wahlkreis in Berlin hat mir eine Grafik
geschickt sie zeigt eine steile Kurve
nicht gezahlter Honorare von 2009 bis
2022 er arbeitet trotzdem weiter weil er
Kinder und Eltern nicht nach Hause
schicken will mich rufen Mütter an die
Händlerin einen Kinderarzt suchen das
sind doch unhaltbare Zustände wir dürfen
unser Gesundheitssystem nicht weiter
kaputt sparen das wäre zutiefst in human
gemeinsam
und nun ist ja die missbotschaft und die
Mangelwirtschaft schon bei der
Medikamentenversorgung angekommen es ist
doch absurd dass in unserem Land
fieberhustensaft zur Mangelware wird
nehmen Sie Ihre Verantwortung dort war
Herr lauterbach
so ganz einfach die Schuldenbremse
schlägt erbarmungslos zu ganz anders als
zum Beispiel bei der Bundeswehr für die
scheint das nicht zu existieren sie von
der Koalition und auch von der Union
haben kein Problem im kommenden Jahr
insgesamt 72 Milliarden Euro für die
Aufrüstung der Bundeswehr auszugeben ich
frage sie sind neue Panzer Flugzeuge und
Granaten mehr wert als die Gesundheit
unserer Bevölkerung nein ich finde es
ist ein humaner Umgang mit kranken
Menschen ein Wert den wir verteidigen
müssen unser Gesundheitssystem darf
nicht kaputt gespart werden herzlichen
Dank
hat einen wichtigen Bereich angesprochen
tatsächlich der mangelnden Kinderärzten
auch der Mangel Ärzten auf dem Land das
ist weiter so und ist auch noch nicht
besser geworden das ist ein
Riesenproblem auch für den Bereich
Gesundheit in Deutschland Carsten klein
jetzt der Berichterstatter der FDP
denn liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Etat ist Gesundheitsministers war
natürlich in den letzten Jahren massiv
dominiert von den Ausgaben für die
Bekämpfung des Coronavirus in 2021 haben
wir 28,9 Milliarden Euro für die
Bekämpfung für Ausgaben 2022 in diesem
Jahr
7,47,3 Milliarden Euro geplant und jetzt
für 2023 nach der Bereinigungssitzung
4,9 Milliarden Euro das sind Ausgaben
für die Ausgleichszahlungen in den
Krankenhäusern für die
Pflegeversicherung für die
Krankenversicherung für die persönliche
Schutzausrüstung Masken für impfen fürs
Testen und für Medikamente und diese
großen Zahlen zeigen zum einen das ist
natürlich richtig war in einer Krise mit
massiven Haushaltsmitteln gegen diese
Krise anzukämpfen aber sie zeigen auch
jetzt wo die Pandemie am Auslaufen ist
dass wir diese Haushaltsmittel auch
wieder ausschleifen lassen liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen denn
krisenstrukturen dürfen nicht auf Dauer
finanziert werden
und da ist ja die Diskussion um die
testverordnung in den letzten Tagen
wirklich symbolisch gewesen Herr
Minister ich möchte mich an der Stelle
auch noch mal ausdrücklich bei Ihnen und
bei ihrem Haus bedanken aber auch bei
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
koalitionsfraktion wir sind uns nicht
über einig welche Maßnahmen in welcher
Geschwindigkeit ausgeschrieben werden
sollen was zurückgefahren werden muss am
Ende erzielen wir immer gute Kompromisse
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in diesem
Land und nach einem Zwischenschritt im
Sommer wo wir ja schon die anlasslosen
die symptomfreien Tests mit einer
Zuzahlung belegt haben fokussieren wir
uns jetzt im nächsten Schritt der
Minister auf die hularabenden Gruppen in
den Krankenhäusern in den Pflegeheimen
zu Hause das setzt den richtigen Akzent
in der jetzigen Situation und ist der
Lage angemessen
wenn alle offiziellen Statistiken egal
ob ich mit die inzidenzwerte anschaue
die Hospitalisierung oder auch die die
aufgrund von Corona auf Intensivstation
behandelt werden müssen gehen ja Gott
sei Dank alle zurück diese Zahlen dürfen
uns aber nicht davor abhalten auch die
Lehren aus dieser Krise zu ziehen und
ich glaube bei einer Lehre sind wir uns
in dem Haus alle einig außer einer
Fraktion nämlich wenn es darum geht dass
wir Pandemie nur gemeinsam international
bekämpfen können und deshalb ist es
richtig deshalb ist es richtig dass die
Koalition die Mittel für die
internationale Gesundheitsversorgung
noch mal um 4,75 Millionen Euro in der
Bereinigungssitzung aufwachsen lassen
hat da auch noch mal ganz herzlichen
Dank an die Kolleginnen der
koalitionsfraktion liebes Svenja Liebe
Paula aber natürlich auch lieber Helga
an euch ich will aber trotzdem da auch
noch mal richtig stellen wenn man die
bei der internationalen
Gesundheitsversorgung akter
herausrechnet also die Mittel die in der
corona-krise wirken sollten vor allem
bei der internationalen Impfkampagne
dann sind die Mittel Aufwüchse im
Vergleich zum Beispiel zu 2020 geben wir
45 Millionen Euro mehr aus für die
internationale Gesundheitsversorgung in
2023 und deshalb glaube ich kann man von
einem
rückwärtsgewandten Schritt hier nicht
sprechen eine weitere Lehre muss
natürlich die Frage sein wie wir in
Zukunft wir die Aufgabenverteilung
zwischen Bund und Ländern richtig
justieren eigentlich ist das klar
geregelt
katastrophenschutzinfektionsschutz ist
Ländersache und deshalb müssen die
Länder jetzt die Vorbereitungen treffen
in der nächsten Pandemie auch aus
eigener Kraft handlungsfähig zu sein da
geht es um die Digitalisierung des
öffentlichen Gesundheitsdienst die jetzt
vom Bund wieder mitfinanziert wird da
geht es natürlich um die Frage wer
trifft denn Vorsorge für Personen die
Schutzausrüstungen in Zukunft alles
länderaufgaben und deshalb Minister
glaube ich neben den anderen Aufgaben
müssen wir auch hier in Gespräche
eintreten dass die Länder jetzt ihre
Aufgabenliste eigentlich erfüllen um in
der nächsten Pandemie dann auch
schlagkräftig zu sein
die Herausforderung im Gesundheitssystem
sind mannigfaltig Digitalisierung ist
ein großes Thema deshalb ist es auch
richtig dass wir gemeinsam in der
Koalition noch mal 5 Millionen Euro für
die digitale gesundheitsagentur in der
Bereinigungssitzung zur Verfügung
gestellt haben wir können enorme
Potenziale mit der Digitalisierung im
Gesundheitssystem heben das macht aber
auch erforderlich dass auch hier die
Länder mit sie nämlich wenn digitale
Infrastruktur in den Krankenhäusern
investiert werden muss das ist
Ländersache dafür gibt es einen
bundestopf zur anfinanzierung aber die
Länder müssen auch hier ihre
Verantwortung endlich gerecht werden
und dann ist es absolut richtig dass wir
als Koalition natürlich den
Krankenhäusern auch in dieser
Energiekrise helfen die Krankenhäuser
werden unter dem unter der Gas- und
strompreisbremse natürlich auch
subsumiert werden die werden daneben
noch den Härtefall vorgekommen alles das
was wir diese Woche ja haushalterisch
auch auf den Weg bringen das heißt diese
Vorsorge ist getroffen jetzt muss es
natürlich noch gesetzgeberisch umgesetzt
werden aber das sind wir auf einem sehr
guten Zielgeraden und deshalb glaube ich
können sich die Krankenhäuser in dieser
Krise auf diese Koalition verlassen und
sie sollten sich in Zukunft auch auf die
Länder verlassen können damit sie
endlich ihren Investitionen abbauen
vielen Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
vielen Dank Herr Kollege klein
das Wort hat nun der Kollege Dinosaurier
die gesundheitspolitische Sprecher der
Union
Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
ich finde das ja toll dass ich jetzt
hier auch die die Haushälter noch mal so
oben haben und sagen wie toll die
Haushaltsberatung waren aber das kann
natürlich nicht darüber hinweg täuschen
dass die
Haushaltsplanung so wie sie jetzt sind
und die Ampel im Grunde ein einziger
Widerspruch sind das kann ich Ihnen
nicht ersparen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und ich sage Ihnen auch warum
wir haben ja die Situation dass wir von
der pandemischen Lage in der endemischen
Lage übergehen und da wäre es ja auch
Aufgabe gewesene der Koalition des
Ministers das entspricht dem Haushalt
auch abzubilden mein Kollege Braun hat
er darauf hingewiesen wir haben die
völlig skurrile Situation dass wir auf
der einen Seite jetzt eine Impfkampagne
von 60 Millionen für das nächste Jahr
bekommen sollen obwohl überhaupt nicht
klar ist wie diese Impfkampagne beim
Bürger ankommen soll und insofern sage
ich Ihnen auch Herr Minister sie haben
auch der Kampagne ein Bärendienst
erwiesen als sie gesagt haben das sein
alles Bereich der Menschen und dann
stellt sich heraus dass es gecastete
Schauspieler waren also das sollten uns
so in der Form nicht antun und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es gibt ja wie
gesagt durchaus gute Nachrichten also
die gute Nachricht ist dass die
pandemische Lage sich entspannt
glücklicherweise auch viele
panikprognosen des Ministers so nicht
eingetreten sind und insofern hätte ich
mir auch gewünscht hätten wir uns auch
als Unionsfraktion gewünscht dass in den
Haushaltsberatungen viele gute
Anregungen die wir gebracht haben auch
berücksichtigt worden werden und
insofern muss man sich doch auch
überlegen ist das sinnvoll 2,9
Milliarden in den Haushalt fürs nächste
Jahr einzustellen für Impfstoffe in dem
Wissen dass wir schon jetzt Millionen
von Dosen verwerfen werden müssen weil
wir leider auch diese Dosen nicht
verimpft bekommen insofern hat das mit
haushaltswahrheit und haushaltsklarheit
an der Stelle überhaupt nichts zu tun
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Minister Lauterbach genau das ist
ja der große Widerspruch in ihrer
Haushaltspolitik einerseits reduzieren
sie Testangebote sie beenden Client die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht wo wir
als Union schon vor Monaten darauf
hingewiesen haben sich da klar zu
positionieren und nicht auf dem Rücken
der Pflegekräfte auszutragen wie diese
einrichtungsbezogen in Pflicht
letztendlich ausläuft sie wird zum
Jahresende auslaufen das ist gut aber
hätte schon viel früher passieren müssen
insgesamt muss man sagen läuft die
Debatte ein Haushalt unter Vorbehalt die
Ampel lässt alle großen Fragen zur
Finanzierung offen und ich sage Ihnen
auch warum GKV finanzstabilisierung der
gesetzlichen Krankenkassen da machen Sie
eine kleinere Form aber gehen nicht die
strukturellen Reform an im Bereich der
Krankenhäuser zeigen sie jetzt ja es
kommt eine Hilfe aber die größere Form
kommt erst im nächsten oder übernächsten
Jahr in der Pflegeversicherung tun sie
nichts bei der Frage Digitalisierung ist
alles auf Standby gesetzt also insofern
gehen sie endlich ins Handeln über das
ist ein Haushalt ich sagte genau wie die
Ampel voller Widersprüche das ist für
solides Haushalten viel viel zu wenig es
ist jetzt ein Jahr Regierungszeit vorbei
kommen sie endlich ins Handeln und es
umsetzen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
ja und die Vorwürfe der Opposition die
kann jetzt der zuständige Bundesminister
direkt beantworten Karl Lauterbach hat
jetzt das Wort
Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Kolleginnen und Kollegen zunächst einmal
diese Haushalt ist geprägt durch ein
Nebeneinander der Bewältigung von großen
Krisen Pandemie wo keine Krieg
Energiekrise Inflationsanstieg also
große Krisen und auf der anderen Seite
notwendigen Reformen und diese Reformen
sind immer unmittelbar notwendige Formen
und Gestaltungen und alle Bereiche gehen
wir an gehen wir mit das ist auch das
was uns erwartet werden kann wir gehen
alle Bereiche an aber bevor ich hier
ausführe möchte ich mich erst einmal
ganz herzlich bedanken bei allen die
diesen Weg mitgehen wir arbeiten ja
derzeit mit sehr hoher Taktung das geht
für die Haushälter vielen Dank an alle
Fraktionen was die Haushälter angeht ich
bedanke mich bei den Fraktionen bei den
Gesundheitspolitikern ich möchte mich
aber auch bedanken bei den vielen
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern im BMG
und den untergeordneten Institutionen
das Tempo ist derzeit hoch wir haben
viel vor uns aber ohne
Mitarbeiter das Miteinander diesen
Teamgeist würde es nicht funktionieren
da man dank auch an alle hier im Haus
die konstruktiv mitgearbeitet haben
ich komme
zunächst groß zur Pandemie zu sprechen
hier ist die gute Nachricht ja es ist so
wir haben hier Hinweise auf eine
Entschärfung der Situation das hängt
damit zusammen dass die Art und Weise
wie das Virus sich weiter also
verbreitet in einer Sackgasse zu geraten
scheint in dem eben nur noch geringe
Veränderungen möglich sind für das Virus
noch ansteckender zu werden somit gehen
diesbezüglich tatsächlich die
Nachrichten wissenschaftlich in die
richtige Richtung wenn es jetzt keine
sprunginnovation durch das Virus mehr
gibt dann sehen wir tatsächlich im
nächsten Jahr Möglichkeiten mit dem
Virus ganz anders umzugehen aber an der
gleichen Stelle möchte ich jetzt auch
sagen verlieren wir jetzt verlieren wir
jetzt bitte nicht die Geduld wir die
vernünftigen hier im Haus denn wenn wir
diese fair wenn wir diese wenn wir diese
Zeit noch
bewältigen wenn wir jetzt die Feiertage
ab werden wir die älteren Menschen und
die vorerkrankten jetzt absichern werden
wir noch einmal vorsichtig sind dann
können wir mit einer Bilanz durch diese
Pandemie gehen die besser ist als die
viele andere europäische Länder daran
haben alle hier mit beigetragen da hat
auch die
Opposition auch die Union mit
beigetragen daher bitte ich um ihre
Hilfe ihre Geduld wir haben hier noch
ein paar Monate wo ich schwerer sein
wird dann können wir anders damit
umgehen lassen Sie uns bitte jetzt nicht
im Stich und auch nicht diejenigen die
auf unsere Hilfe angewiesen sind
ich möchte es auch sagen also
beispielsweise die Aufhebung der
isolationspflicht das ist eine total
legitime Frage eine vollkommen legitime
Frage aber wir wollen bei der
isolationspflicht erst einmal bleiben
weil diejenigen die zur Arbeit gehen die
beispielsweise Risikofaktoren haben die
erkrankt sind krebskranke leukämiekranke
diejenigen die sich nicht gut durch
Impfung schützen können die verdienen
einen sicheren Arbeitsplatz das müssen
wir wahrnehmen die isolationspflicht ist
die Möglichkeit die wir haben und zu
verhindern dass der Einzelne nicht in
Angst sich am Arbeitsplatz aufhalten
muss
die Reformen die vor uns legen
betreffend vier Bereiche zum einen die
Finanzierung dabei haben wir große
finanzierungsreformen vor uns bei der
gesetzlichen Krankenversicherung aber
auch bei der Pflege große Defizite
mussten bereits beseitigt werden aber
wir machen eine große
Finanzierungsreform werden in der
Pflegeversicherung in zwei Schritten
vorgehen zunächst bis zum 1.7 den
Beitragssatz stabilisieren dann werden
wir die Leistungen dynamisieren und auch
die eigenen Anteile in der Pflege
reduzieren wir werden darüber hinaus in
der Krankenversicherung den Steueranteil
für Arbeitslosengeld II Empfänger und
auch den Steuerzuschuss erhöhen müssen
so dass sie Finanzstabilität der GKV
gesichert ist aber wir haben erst einmal
hier eine Reform gemacht womit wir Lage
stabilisiert haben wir machen jetzt die
Strukturreform das gleiche machen wir
auch im Krankenhaus Sektor im
Krankenhaussektor hat es unmittelbare
Handlungsbedarf gegeben wir brauchen
unmittelbar eine Lösung für die
Kinderkliniken Kinderkliniken waren von
der Insolvenz bedroht wir brauchen
unmittelbar eine situationsverbesserung
in der Geburtshilfe in der Geburtshilfe
die kleinen Geburtshilfe Kliniken kommen
nicht zurecht da wird dort unmittelbar
reagiert wir brauchen eine Lösung für
die tagesstationäre Versorgung weil oft
übernachten die Patienten im Krankenhaus
nur weil der Fall sonst nicht
abgerechnet werden kann es gibt keine
medizinischen Gründe dafür dass
beseitigen wird und wir müssen endlich
einen neuen Sektor schaffen dass die
gleiche Leistung die im Ausland längst
ambulant erbracht werden kann auch bei
uns ambulant erbracht werden kann so
dass wir dort Pflegekräfte entlasten
diese Patienten werden in Deutschland
nur deshalb noch stationär versorgt weil
es sonst nicht gemacht werden kann daher
diese schnellen Reformen und ein Pflege
entlassungsgesetz bringen wir auf den
Weg und an dem Tag nachdem wir diese
Gesetze beschlossen haben an dem Tag
nachdem wir diese Gesetze beschlossen
haben werden wir auch schon unser
Konzept für eine größere Formen im
Krankenhaus vorstellen wo wir die
Überwindung der Fallpauschalen
vorstellen darauf warten wir seit 20
Jahren seit 20 Jahren wissen wir dass
das fahrpauschalengesetz zu einem
Hamsterrad Effekt in den Kliniken
geführt hat und wir werden jetzt nach 20
Jahren werden wir diese Reform für
durchführen somit wir arbeiten im hohen
Tempo und wir werden daher die
Krankenhausversorgung deutlich
entökonomisieren und dafür sorgen dass
endlich die medizinische Indikation dass
die medizinische Arbeit wieder voll im
Vordergrund steht und nicht mehr die
ökonomischen Anweisungen
einen ähnlichen Stillstand und es wird
ja hier zu Recht darauf hingewerfen wir
müssen auch an ähnlichen Stillstand
haben wir auch bei der Digitalisierung
bei der Digitalisierung reden wir seit
ewiger Zeit über die Einführung der
elektronischen Patientenakte ne ist es
gekommen jetzt schaffen wir in einem
kurzfristigen Gesetz die dafür
notwendigen Voraussetzungen zum Beispiel
bei der Authentifizierung derjenigen die
dies nutzen wollen und dann schaffen wir
in einem großen digital bis jetzt sofort
danach auch die strukturellen
Voraussetzungen dass sich die
elektronische Patientenakte befüllen
kann schauen wir uns doch an was
international alles möglich war durch
eine gut funktionierende elektronische
Patientenakte was wir nicht machen
konnten wir haben doch viele Dinge in
der Pandemie nicht machen können und
haben von ausländischen Daten
profitieren können die wir zum Glück
bekommen haben aus Israel wir wollen
demnächst so weit sein dass sich das
Deutschland auch für unsere
Informationen und Daten interessiert und
dass wir nicht die Bittsteller sind für
Daten in anderen Ländern weil wir die
elektronische Patientenakte nie auf den
Weg gebracht haben daran arbeitet die
aber wir reden nicht darüber Sorge wir
machen es und zwar mit höchster
Geschwindigkeit
zumindest erlauben sie zwei
Zwischenfragen aus den Fraktionen von
der Sorge CD CSU und aus der Fraktion
DIE LINKE ich würde die Zwischenfrage
zulassen werden
Tino Sorge CDU vielen Dank Herr
Bundesgesundheitsminister das Thema
Datennutzung will ich gar nicht weiter
adressieren weil wir hätten in der
letzten Legislatur die Möglichkeiten
gehabt beim forschungsdatenzentrum auch
Datennutzung besser zu ermöglichen nicht
nur für öffentliche Institution sondern
auch für private Unternehmen forschende
Gesundheitsunternehmen das ist leider an
ihrem Widerstand gescheitert das muss
ich hier mal so klar sagen aber mich
würde eher interessieren sie haben jetzt
wieder viel angekündigt welche Reformen
geplant sind was kommen soll und deshalb
würde mich ganz konkret interessieren
wann kommt der Entwurf zur
krankenhausstrukturreform vielen Dank
vielen Dank für die Frage ich hoffe dass
wir in die die wichtig ich sag mal fünf
große Reformen im Krankenhaus die
Entlastung bei der also Energie Gaspreis
Strompreis indirekte Energiekosten
hoffen wir in der nächsten Woche
beschlossen zu haben in der nächsten
Woche hoffen wir zu beschließen das kam
aus pflegen lassen zu setzen dann als
dritte Reform wir hoffen in der wir
werden in der nächsten Woche beschließen
die bessere Vergütung der Kinderkliniken
als förderreform wir werden in der
nächsten Woche beschließen dass die
Geburtshilfe besser bezahlt wird als
Fünfter Reform wir werden in der
nächsten Woche beschließen dass die
tagesstationäre Versorgung eingeführt
wird und als sexreform wir werden in der
nächsten Woche beschließen dass sie über
die kommen somit haben wir sechs
Reformen die kommen in der letzten
Legislaturperiode hat es keine einzige
gegeben nur zur Erinnerung und daher
glaube ich können wir gut darstellen und
werden unmittelbar unmittelbar nachdem
wir diese sechs Reformen gebracht haben
werden wir das große der
Expertenkommission Regierungskommission
Krankenhaus vorbereitete
drg-reformgesetz vorliegen wo wir die
DRGs dann überwinden werden somit werden
wir in sehr kurzer Zeit sehr intensiv
arbeiten das haben wir auch in den
letzten Wochen schon getan und ich muss
offen sagen wenn ich ganz direkt hier
sein kann das ist einfach was wir jetzt
machen sind zum Teil
aufholarbeiten von Reformen die über
Jahre hinweg liegen geblieben sind
so die weitere Frage aus der Familie
vielen vielen Dank dass Sie die Frage
zulassen ich bin auch über die
Ankündigung sehr gespannt die sie immer
wieder machen ich möchte auf eine Sache
Hinweisen dieses Jahr im Haushalt nicht
mehr vorhanden ist im letzten Jahr war
und über sich sehr viele Pflegekräfte
wieder beschweren möchte ich frage mit
der Hoffnung verbinden dass sich an die
Kollegen Kollegen an die Pflege wenden
können um diesen flexit noch zu
verhindern da jetzt gerade wieder erneut
ansteht ich spreche von den eine
Milliarden der Kollege plantate hat
gleich 1000 Millionen genannt dass es
Pflege Bonus den Pflegekräften zur
Verfügung stand es kommt jetzt gerade
bei den Leuten an wie viele Menschen es
in der Pflege nicht bekommen werden wie
viele von diesen Pflege Bonus nicht
berücksichtigt werden das wird sagen
nach dem klatschen was zwei Jahre lang
um 9 Uhr immer anhielt sagen die
Leistung die auch ausgezahlt wurde an
den Pflegekräften das merken die
Menschen jetzt die sich noch in der
Pflege befinden was bei Ihnen alles
nicht ankommt und wer das ganze Geld
nicht erhält jetzt haben sie eine
erneute Ankündigung für eine Pflege
Entlastung nächstes nächste Woche die
von dem Finanzminister also eine
Vorbehalt der Finanzierung des finanzmin
das steht und ich möchte Sie bitten an
sich an die Pflegekräfte zu wenden mit
welchen Reformen sie den Menschen helfen
werden dass sie wirklich sich noch in
der Pflege befinden oder wieder zur
Pflege zurückkommen werden weil momentan
liegt nichts vor was diesen
Pflegekräften irgendwie in den flexit
irgendwie Einhalt gebieten wird vielen
vielen Dank
artiscopin
gesagt fällt es mir sehr schwer diese
Frage zu beantworten weil
offenbar folgen Sie dann die
Diskussionen nicht wie wir seit Monaten
im Ausschuss haben aber schon ausgeführt
wir machen das Pflege das Kranken aus
pflegeentlastungsgesetz der Pflege
Bundes ist umgesetzt es gibt mehr als
3000 Euro in der Krankenpflege in der
also in der stationären Pflege und in
den Pflegeeinrichtungen sind die Mittel
ausgezahlt worden da hat es am Anfang
kurz zur Verzögerungen gegeben darüber
haben wir berichtet dass die behoben
werden konnten somit sind die Pflege
wurden die ausgezahlt das
krankenhauspflege entlastungsgesetz
sieht darüber hinaus vor
bitte lassen Sie also wenn Sie eine
Frage stellen dann wäre es höflich wenn
sie nicht zwischen reden oder sonst
ja es macht keinen Unterschied also wenn
sie in der Fraktion so höflich wenn sie
in der Fraktion so höflich sein könnten
dass ich den dass ich ihrem Kollegen
Frage beantworten kann wir haben
wirklich im krankenhauspflege
entlastungsgesetz haben wir zahlreiche
Maßnahmen die Pflege unmittelbar lassen
will zum Beispiel die tagesstationär
Versorgung dann müssen werden als
zahlreiche nach Dienste nicht notwendig
sein wenn wir durch das Hybrid der die
Gesetz dazu führen dass diese vielen
vielen stationären Aufenthalte die wir
nur haben damit sie abgerechnet werden
können wenn nicht also ambulant gemacht
werden können dann wird das die Pflege
entlassen können wir werden also in der
Kinderkrankenpflege und auch in der
Geburtshilfe werden wir die Pflege
entlassen wir rechnen die Hebammen
komplett auf das pflege-budget an das
geht mir die Möglichkeit auch zu
berichtigen was sie falsch gesagt haben
verlöte also auch die Hebammen werden
nicht von den Krankenhäusern bezahlt
sondern wird von den Krankenkassen
bezahlte selbst der in ihrem Beitrag war
das was ich will nur sagen es geht Dir
wirklich nicht und Polemik sondern es
geht darum dass wir die Gesetze die wir
durchaus kritisch diskutieren dass wir
sie auch wirkt dass uns die Mühe machen
die Gesetze wirklich auch zu verstehen
denn es gibt immer auch also sozusagen
in der Umsetzung Differenzen da lernt
man voneinander aber diese Frage zeigt
aus meiner Sicht ohne dass ich ihr
polemisch erscheinen möchte dass sie
sich nicht ausreichend mit dem Gesetz
beschäftigt haben
ich komme zu den digitalen Bereich so
wir werden im Bereich der
Digitalisierung somit die
Voraussetzungen für elektronische
Patienten anzubringen wir werden Sie
dann umsetzen und wir brauchen da große
Würfe wir wollen wieder dort führen sein
und lassen sie mich zum Schluss auf
einen Bereich noch zu sprechen kommen
der ebenfalls in massiver Form
reformbedürftig ist wir müssen ein
Versorgungsgesetz machen für die
Menschen die in den Gesundheitssystemen
arbeiten und zwar in jedem Bereich wir
brauchen mehr Medizin Studierende wir
brauchen endlich die Umsetzung des
Masterplans 2020 wir brauchen eine
bessere probationsordnung wir brauchen
eine bessere Regelung der Ausbildung der
Psychotherapeuten wir brauchen eine
verbesserte Verteilung der
Psychotherapeuten so dass man auch dort
versorgt werden kann wo ist von den
Verhältnissen der prekär ist wir
brauchen mehr Pflegepersonal aus dem
Ausland aber nicht von dort wo das auch
gebraucht wird und wir brauchen eine
bessere Ausbildung in den Heilberufen
miteinander
akademisierten Ausbildungen und der
beruflichen Ausbildung auch das werden
wir alles angehen somit wir haben viel
vor uns ich darf mich bei allen bedanken
die bereit sind diesen Weg konstruktiv
mit uns zu gehen und kann nur sagen es
ist richtig zu verlangen dass wir
anpacken aber ich kann nur sagen in
diesem Bereich gilt die Ampel wirkt und
arbeitet
vielen Dank Herr Minister
Karl Lauterbach der
Bundesgesundheitsminister hat unter
anderem Zuschüsse zu Beschaffung von
Impfstoffen gegen kovid von 3,2
Milliarden Euro für das kommende Jahr in
seinem Haushalt in diesem Jahr waren es
noch 7,9 Milliarden Euro und es gibt
nicht wenige in diesem Land die im
vorwerfen die Pandemie künstlich zu
verlängern der nächste Redner jetzt in
dieser Debatte kommt von der AFD
verstanden
Tino Sorge noch mal mit einer
Kurzintervention und hat er nicht vorhin
schon eine Zwischenfrage gestellt und ja
aber Wolfgang Kubik lässt sie zu
Intervention auch auf Hybriden Wege
zulassen also ja ich möchte noch mal
darauf eingehen weil der Herr Minister
ja jetzt gerade eben auch auf die Frage
meines Kollegen aus Linksfraktion wieder
so getan hat bei der konkreten Frage
warum bekommt nicht jede Pflegefachkraft
diesen Pflege Bonus wieder mit vielen
Worten nichts gesagt hat der Minister er
hat überhaupt nicht beantwortet weil ich
kann Ihnen das nicht ersparen
Entschuldigung wir bekommen alle massiv
Briefe dass uns Pflegefachkräfte
anschreiben und fragen warum bekommen
auf bestimmten Station
Pflegefachkräfte die nebeneinander am
Bett Patienten gepflegt haben in der
corona-pandemie warum bekommt der eine
oder die eine die Bonus und die anderen
nicht und ich kann Ihnen sagen woran das
liegt weil sie nicht nachjustieren weil
sie nicht sagen jeder soll das bekommen
und ich will ihn mal ich will ihn mal
vorlesen war ja hier immer so getan hat
als sei das nicht so und was
Mitarbeiterin dazu sagen die sagen ganz
normal dass dieser Bonus die
Sonderzahlungen für Kolleginnen und
Kollegen die auf der gleichen Station
Arbeiten unterschiedlich gewährt wird
also einmal wird er gewährt einmal gar
nicht und der Grund bleibe für sie
völlig undurchsichtig was hier abgeht
ist ein Skandal und ein tritt für alle
Mitarbeiter im Gesundheitswesen die in
den vergangenen zwei Jahren wirklich bis
auf die Knochen alles gegeben haben das
Sagen Pflegefachkräfte Herr Minister und
jetzt würde mich wirklich interessieren
warum differenzieren sie da wir haben
schon vor Monaten hier in diesem Hohen
Haus den Antrag gestellt den Pflege
Bonus für alle Pflegefachkräfte zu
zahlen für Rettungskräfte für
Feuerwehrleute und Sie können doch nicht
sagen die klatschen schön das ist ja
angesprochen worden und wenn es dann um
die konkrete Dankbarkeit geht die sie ja
immer vollmundig überall erklären dann
differenzieren sie zwischen
Pflegefachkräften was dazu führt dass
die Akzeptanz vor Ort auch nicht mehr da
ist und mittlerweile Pflegefachkräfte
sogar sagen es wäre besser gewesen man
hätte diesen pflege-bonus überhaupt
nicht ins Leben gerufen anstatt diesen
Ärger vor Ort zu produzieren wo niemand
mehr versteht warum jemand den Bonus
bekommt und jemand anderes nicht
wenn wir jetzt möchten sie darauf
reagieren
ja vielen Dank ich finde es immer wieder
schade muss offen sagen wenn wir hier
etwas tun was also vielen
berechtigterweise hilft die also
Pflegekräfte verdienen diese
Unterstützung nehmen sie auch an
bedanken sich und es sind die
Pflegekräfte am Bett ich finde es immer
wieder schade wenn wir Geld ausgeben
wenn wir versuchen zu helfen und dann
wird dann ohne dass man genau wird an
wenigen Einzelbeispielen die
möglicherweise dann sogar stimmen das
ist ganz anders aber ich würde auch an
Sie die bitte richten wenn ich auf ihre
Frage eingehe dass sie mir die
Möglichkeit dann geben so bitte ich
überhaupt ans Haus gerichtet an die
demokratischen Parteien hier im Haus wir
sollten uns kein Beispiel an der AFD
nehmen sondern uns aussehen lassen die
wenigen Fälle die es gibt die vielen die
wenigen Fälle die es gibt da sind weg
wirklich Fälle dabei die berechtigt sind
es ist tatsächlich so es wird ja
umgesetzt von den Krankenhäusern es gibt
berechtigte Fälle wo jemand den
bundesverdient und bekommt nicht wir
gehen wirklich jedem einzelnen dieser
Fälle nach aber es ist nicht richtig
dann den Eindruck zu wecken als wenn die
gesamte Reform nicht funktionieren würde
und als wenn wir die Pflegekräfte nicht
würdig hier bedienen würde wir haben es
bei den Pflegekräften ehrlich bedankt
wir haben den Bonus so umgesetzt wie es
uns richtig zu sein wir haben uns nicht
bezüglich mit den pflegeverbänden
intensivst abgestimmt wenn es kleine
Lücke noch gibt es das Okay gehen wir
demnach aber der falsche Eindruck um
hier ein paar oppositions Malen zu
machen dass wir uns um die Pflegekräfte
nicht kümmern würden das ist nicht
redlich und er spricht auch nicht Datum
unserer Regierung
vielen Dank Herr Minister nächster
Kollege Wolfgang gieler afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Kolleginnen
und Kollegen zwei einhalb Milliarden
Euro ungefähr so viel wie der gesamte
umweltetat umfasst hat die Koalition
alleine in den Haushaltsberatungen noch
mal auf den gesundheitshaushalt
aufgeschlagen und alle größeren Posten
drehen sich wieder um einen alten
Bekannten um das Coronavirus
die meisten Länder dieser Welt behandeln
kobit 19 inzwischen ähnlich wie eine
Grippe aber in Deutschland gibt es
weiterhin schlimme Wellen nämlich
panikwellen die freilich dann von der
Wirklichkeit widerlegt werden
der größte Aufschlag trägt wieder einmal
die Überschrift Beschaffung von
Impfstoff
nur verschoben aus 2022 warum werden
überflüssige Bestellungen nicht
verschoben nicht storniert statt
verschoben
hat Frau von der Leyen die Verträge mit
der Pharma-Lobby im Hinterzimmer so
schlecht verhandelt
dass die EU und auch Deutschland nicht
mehr herauskommen
die Hersteller haben sich schon dumm und
dusselig verdient Herr Minister
Lauterbach kümmern sie sich endlich ums
Gemeinwohl und sorgen Sie für eine
Lösung
stattdessen wird nun für zusätzliche 60
Millionen eine neue Impfkampagne
aufgelegt ich frage mich sehr ob ihr
medizinische Kriterien entscheidend
waren oder doch eher die Weiterführung
des Geschäftes mit der Angst
die Medien die an den neuen 60
Werbemillionen prächtig verdienen werden
auch kaum durch kritische
Berichterstattung auffangen
spätestens für die nächsten
Bundeshaushalt wird auch die geplante
krankenhausreform eine wichtige Rolle
spielen viele krankenhaushäuser behalten
Patienten über Nacht da um mehr zu
verdienen das muss geändert werden sie
haben das angesprochen
aber wenn durch eine neue Regelung
künftig das Gegenteil passiert also
Patienten nur aus finanziellen Gründen
über Nacht nach Hause geschickt werden
dann haben wir bei der Reform das Kind
mit dem Bade ausgeschüttet
der medizinische Sachverstand muss
entscheiden
genauso darf mein Kliniken nicht einfach
aus Geldgründen schließen die ländlichen
Gegenden dürfen nicht von der Versorgung
abgehängt werden auch hier muss der
Sachverstand entscheiden
ob künftig der Sachverstand über
Lobby-Interessen siegt werden wir sehen
für die afd-strafaktion ist das der
Maßstab der gesundheitsetat 2023 hat
diesen Test jedenfalls nicht bestanden
deshalb lehnen wir ihn ab
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
nächste Redner ist die Kollegin Maria
klein
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen hier im Raum
liebe Damen und Herren ZuschauerInnen
hier bei der Debatte insgesamt scheint
mir nach dem Vorlauf noch mal wichtig
dass wir das ein bisschen einordnen was
hier im Gesundheitsbereich diskutiert
wird wir reden über einen
gesundheitshaushalt der quasi ergänzend
ist zudem was im Kern eigentlich über
Beitragsfinanzierung läuft und wenn man
sich mal die
Dimensionen klar macht dann reden wir
über ca 20 Milliarden Euro die hier im
Bundeshaushalt eingestellt werden wir
reden aber alleine nächstes Jahr über
300 Milliarden Ausgaben nur über die
gesetzliche Krankenversicherung noch mal
weitere 59 Milliarden Euro für die
soziale Pflegeversicherung das muss sich
jeder klarmachen und das zeigt
ordnungspolitisch auch
das größte Teil aller Aufgaben die wir
hier bewältigen über die
Beitragsfinanzierung läuft und wir
insofern wenn wir über den Haushalt
reden über ergänzende Mittel reden das
ist wichtig damit man weiß wer ist
eigentlich zuständig und das hilft auch
ein bisschen insgesamt die Einordnung zu
haben und wenn wir da schauen dann haben
wir
aus einer corona-zeit einen hohen
Bundeszuschuss geerbt gehabt 65
Milliarden Euro Corona bedingten zahlen
die sind aber zurückgefahren worden ganz
zurecht weil wir eben weniger massive
Auswirkungen haben parallel haben wir
aber eine neue Krise die nämlich mit den
inflationsbedingten und Energie
bedingten Kostensteigerungen zu tun
haben und wir haben die Krise das
sowieso die stationäre Versorgung nicht
privat finanziert war mit Lücken aus den
Ländern mit Lücken auch aus der
bundessicht wenn wir gerade die
pädiatrien angucken und wenn wir die
Geburtshilfen angucken oder die
Notfallversorgung und wir haben es mit
einem gravierenden Fachkräftemangel zu
tun und all diese Dinge sind nicht neu
sondern die sind bestehen schon lange
als Problem sie gehen hier jetzt endlich
an und das ist die Besonderheit und das
führt auch dazu dass wir nicht nur
Krisenbewältigung hier in diesem
Fachbereich haben und mit Leistung und
hoher Leistung aus dem
Gesundheitsministerium sondern dass wir
umfangreichste Strukturreform
vorbereiten und diese in Teilen ja auch
schon in Gesetzesverfahren münden das
ist das was hier geleistet worden ist
und ich finde man kann nach einem Jahr
Ampel sagen ja wir können durchaus stolz
sein da sind wirklich große und
gravierende Themen angegangen haben und
wir haben die wirklich gravierenden
Strukturreformen die Anliegen die
dringend sind die haben wir auf dem Weg
gebracht und das Herr Sorge als Sprecher
der Fraktion würde ich auch von ihnen
erwarten dass sie da Antworten liefern
dass sie uns Antworten liefern wie wir
denn die Finanzlücke in der GKV